ravi de vous retrouver sur public sénat
dans quelques instants vous allez
pouvoir suivre l'audition de fadela
amara la secrétaire d'état chargée de la
politique de la ville est entendu par la
mission commune d'information du sénat
sur la politique en faveur des jeunes
bonne audition à tous la dame madame la
secrétaire d'état merci infiniment
d'être venu jusqu'à jusqu'à nous pour
pour nous aider dans notre réflexion
je ne sais pas s'il faut que je vous
rend si tu es un peu la mission ou
s'éclaire pour pour vous je pense que
savait que nous sommes nous avons fait
cette mission s'est mise en place il ya
peu de temps
trois petites semaines parallèlement au
travail de martin hirsch
il nous a semblé que n'était pas
inintéressant que législatif les
sénateurs réfléchissent également
aux problèmes de la jeunesse et pas
seulement l'exécutif donc on souhaite
terminer en tout cas par un rapport
d'étape au minimum à la fin mais ça veut
dire qu'on s'est laissé très peu de
temps qu'on a fait le choix de
travailler sur la tranche 16-25 ans et
qu'on a également sérier les problèmes
donc ni les âges ni les thèmes retenus
ne sont exhaustifs mais en tout cas nous
avons retenu tout ce qui tourne autour
de l'emploi c'est-à-dire orientation
formation emploi
l'autonomie des jeunes c'est-à-dire
autonomie financière
accès au logement problème d'accès à la
culture et de citoyenneté
mais ce qui nous préoccupe le plus
sont les thèmes autour de l'emploi et
autour de l'autonomie puisque le chômage
des jeunes est ce que vous savez aussi
bien si ce n'est mieux que nous un des
plus élevés d'europe avec une
progression de 32 ou 34 % en un an
on estime à 18% à peu près les jeunes de
16 à 25 ans qui vivent en dessous du
seuil de pauvreté
et ce qui nous bouscule beaucoup aussi
c'est le sentiment de désespoir des gens
qui ont pour la première fois depuis
bien longtemps l'idée que leur vie sera
plus difficile que celle de leurs
parents
voilà donc on voudrait vous entendre sur
tout cela et surtout ce que vous aurez
envie de nous dire sachant que on se
sent quand même un peu frustré d'avoir
laissé de côté le problème spécifique
des jeunes des plus en difficulté c'est
à dire ceux qui sont concentrées dans
les quartiers difficiles dans les
banlieues mais voilà on peut pas on n'a
pas la prétention de 2,2 de brosses et
touchant
et par souci d'efficacité on a ses
limites et à
voilà ce que je vous ai annoncé donc on
vous passe la parole aux bêtises c'est
magique ici
d'abord je voudrais merci madame la
présidente je voudrais d'abord vous
remercier de m'avoir invité à participer
à une commission qui est pour moi tu es
une commission qui est extrêmement
importante dans le sens où ce qui va
émaner de vos travaux de vos réflexions
et vos pistes de travail aussi vont être
en réalité extrêmement importante pour
le devenir de notre pays
j'ai eu l'occasion de le déclarer c'est
pas dans le discours officiel mais je le
dis quand même j'ai eu l'occasion de le
déclarer je pense moi qu'un pays qui
n'est qu'ils ne parie pas sur sa
jeunesse un pays qui ne sait pas faire
confiance à sa jeunesse un pays qui
n'est pas capable de définir un vrai
contrat de confiance avec sa jeunesse
est un p tit crème est un pays qui se
projette pas dans l'avenir est un pays
qui en réalité surtout nous puisque
notre pays est un pays vieillissant et
api qui ne sera pas capable en réalité
de briller sur la scène internationale
et encore moins au niveau européen donc
je suis ravi mois qu'on est à la fois
nommé martin hirsch haut commissaire à
la jeunesse parce que j'ai toujours
affirmé
y compris quand dans mes anciennes
fonctions que c'était important qu'ils
aient cette visibilité politique ça
démontre aussi en réalité là la
détermination que le politique peut
avoir donc je me réjouis que le
président de la république est nommé
martin hirsch à cette fonction là et je
me réjouis aussi de l'existence de cette
commission parce que vous avez raison
c'est pas que l'exécutif qui doit penser
réfléchir et mettre en action c'est ce
qui va évidemment de la responsabilité
de tous les élus et qui mieux en réalité
que ceux qui ont une légitimité total
participe aussi à l'élaboration d'une
future politique en direction de la
jeunesse de notre pays et j'insisterai
par contre la jeunesse de notre pays
évidemment vous l'aurez compris dans
toute sa diversité
alors vous avez précisé que vous avez
pas particulièrement accentué sur une
genèse qui risquent de
payer le prix cher de cette crise et de
l'impact de cette crise majeure que nous
traversons qui sont les quartiers
populaires mais ma présence ici en
réalité prouve aussi votre volonté
d'entendre se tisse son de cloche si je
puis me permettre ce langage parce que
je crois qu'il est important nécessaire
indispensable
et puis surtout parce que je suis
convaincu je sais que certains d'entre
vous partage pour avoir l'occasion de de
discuter avec certains d'entre vous ça y
va aussi évidemment vous l'aurez compris
de la cohésion nationale de notre pays
et donc en réalité du fondement même du
projet républicain
alors madame présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs si vous
permettez je vais donc en réalité
faire un vrai discours qui répondra
aussi incertain ensemble
d'interrogations et qui mettra l'accent
sur les jeunes des quartiers qui
habitent les zones urbaines sensibles
je n'oublie pas tout seul toute la
jeunesse qui existe dans notre pays
particulièrement c'est le cas de vide
dans les zones rurales
mais j'ai la responsabilité dans ce
gouvernement de m'occuper en particulier
dans les responsables du tfg des zones
urbaines sensibles et des gens qui
habitent et donc notamment les jeunes
des quartiers populaires alors les un
peu long mais en réalité et répond
parfaitement je dirais une volonté à la
fois du diagnostic mais pas uniquement
parce que ça suffit pas de faire des
diagnostics
il faut aussi lancer des vraies
perspectives vous savez que moi je
m'inscris particulièrement dans le dans
une dynamique c'est pas pour rien que je
les appelais espoir banlieues une
dynamique pour la france je crois
qu'aujourd'hui notamment face à la crise
à l'impact de la crise il s'agit aussi
d'avoir des discours positif qui
permettent d'aider ceux qui sont les
plus fragiles en particulier dans nos
quartiers de s'inscrire aussi dans la
vigne est alors maintenant la présidente
monsieur rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
je vous remercie de me permettre
aujourd'hui de vous parler d'un sujet
qui me tient particulièrement à coeur
solide de notre jeunesse il est de notre
responsabilité de prendre pleinement
conscience au delà des lieux communs que
la jeunesse est l'avenir de notre pays
ils nous aident à tracer de nouveaux
sillons à construire l'avenir à
anticiper les défis elle est le moteur
mais aussi la condition du changement
social
elle est donc au coeur du projet
républicain mais aujourd'hui notre
jeunesse nous interpelle parce qu'elle
est inquiète quant à son présent
inquiètes quant à sa de devenir une
jeunesse fragilisé vulnérables face à la
crise économique et sociale qui la
frappe de plein fouet comme le montrent
l'aggravation dramatique du chômage des
jeunes
et vous avez raison de rappeler les
chiffres vous le savez le gouvernement
est fortement mobilisée en direction des
jeunes pour atténuer le plus possible
les effets de cette crise et pour les
accompagner vers la sortie de crise où
il savait le présent de la république
présentera des nouvelles mesures en
faveur de l'emploi des jeunes le 20
avril prochain
donc je vais pas déflorer je dirais le
discours et les annonces du président de
la république mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs pour élaborer une politique en
direct
de la jeunesse il me semble important de
bien savoir ce que l'on entend quand on
parle de la jeunesse la jeunesse est
d'abord une classe d'âge homogène qui 1
1 comme un dégoût des habitudes un
langage et une même volonté de se
projeter dans le monde
en france on est jeunes de 16 à 24 ans
mais en réalité on est jeunes jusqu'à 30
ans l'allongement des études l'année
tardive dans la vie active les
difficultés pour trouver un logement
tous ces facteurs font que l'on reste
ses parents beaucoup plus tard qu'il ya
15 ou 20 ans la grande dépendance la
grande précarité dans laquelle vit notre
jeunesse est une autre caractéristique
actuelle les jeunes sont plus souvent
qu'avant cdd ou en intérim
ils sont de plus en plus touchés par le
chômage ils sont en première ligne dès
que l'activité économique a ralenti et
nous le vivons actuellement les
conditions de vie des jeunes sont en
général beaucoup plus difficile que pour
les générations précédentes notamment
pour l'accès au logement sans même
envisager de devenir propriétaires
beaucoup de jeunes qui travaillent sont
dans l'impossibilité de payer un loyer
tous les mois malgré les efforts du
gouvernement et notamment sur le plan de
la caution nous sommes donc face à une
situation extrêmement grave puisque dans
notre pays un jeune sur cinq vit
aujourd'hui en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté soit plus d'un million et demi
de personnes
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
quand on regarde de près cette réalité
sociale
on voit très nettement que la jeunesse
n'est pas un groupe uni forme si
certains pensent la jeunesse dans une
globalité en la considérant comme une
classe sociale qui a besoin d'une
réponse globale et uniforme et d'une
politique plus globale la réalité montre
que la jeunesse était trop jeune la
jeunesse est marquée par de fortes
disparités sociales qui reflète
d'ailleurs les déséquilibres et les
inégalités de notre société
il n'y a donc pas une jeunesse à
proprement parler il y a ceux qui sont
privilégiés et ceux qui ne le sont pas
il ya ceux qui ont qu'ils ont et ceux
qui n'ont pas et au premier rang de ceux
qui n'ont pas ou pas suffisamment
il y a les jeunes des quartiers et des
banlieues en difficultés car c'est dans
les quartiers mais aussi dans les zones
rurales que se concentre le chômage qui
est en moyenne deux fois supérieur à la
moyenne nationale et tous en premier
lieu les jeunes qu'ils soient ou non
diplômés avec un taux de chômage de 30%
depuis et non dans les zones urbaines
sensibles le nombre de jeunes inscrits
au chômage a progressé de plus de 50%
est doublé pour les diplômés bac + 3 ou
plus et ça ce n'est pas tolérable
alors oui c'est important de mobiliser
la jeunesse mais face à cette crise
économique sans précédent nous devons
surtout apporter des réponses concrètes
immédiates et sur mesure à ces jeunes
qui sont les plus fragilisés
cela ne signifie pas que nous devons
figé les jeunes dans une catégorie celle
de la jeunesse des quartiers défavorisés
les jeunes des quartiers ont trop
longtemps été laissé pour compte tout
comme les autres habitants de ces
territoires dans un assistanat qui n'a
que trop duré mesdames et messieurs dans
notre pays vieillissant c'est bien dans
les quartiers populaires que se trouve
la majorité de notre jeunesse et donc
notre avenir
ce que je constate à chacune de mes
visites de terrain sait que c'est
quartier regorge de potentiel et de
forces vives et je sais que nous sommes
nombreux à partager les jeunes font
preuve plus qu'ailleurs de créativité et
d'une certaine nya qu ils sont des
consommateurs précurseur la moitié
d'entre eux veut créer sa propre
entreprise bref les jeunes des quartiers
sont des acteurs dont notre économie ne
peut pas se passer au siècle dernier les
habitants de nos quartiers et banlieues
populaires ont été les forces vives de
la nation qui ont porté la croissance à
bout de bras qui ont permis à la france
de se relever des guerres de la crise et
de construire les trente glorieuses des
jeunes des quartiers sont aujourd'hui
porteur du même potentiel du même espoir
pour notre pays pour peu qu'on remette
en route l'ascenseur social pour qu'on
puisse poursuivre la lutte contre les
discriminations et qu'on renforce le
projet républicain
c'est tout le sens des déclarations du
président de la république sur la
promotion de la diversité sociale sur sa
volonté que les quartiers et les
banlieues deviennent vivier des
compétences et des élites de la france
de demain
car comme il l'a déclaré avec force un
pays je cite un pays qui recrutent ces
élites dans 10 % de la population
c'est tout simplement un pays qui se
privent de 90% de son intelligence c'est
comme si la france ne faisait que six
millions d'habitants
il ne s'agit en aucun cas de faire
l'aumône où la charité nous devons
donner aux jeunes des outils pour les
aider à prendre leur place s'émanciper
construire leur avenir
et cela ne pourra passer que par
l'éducation cela passera par la
formation
cela passera par la patrie
l'apprentissage et cela passera blu ray
compris aussi par le travail
mesdames et messieurs je voudrais leur
affirmer avec force aujourd'hui devant
vous la cohésion nationale et l'avenir
du projet républicain se joue aussi dans
nos quartiers populaires la politique de
la ville et donc une politique d'intérêt
général qui relèvent de la
responsabilité de tous c'est pour cette
raison qu'elle est par essence
interministériel partenariale et
contractuels je vous rappelle que chaque
ministre doit désormais rendre des
comptes sur l'avancement de ces
programmes triennaux en faveur des
quartiers tous les trimestres dans le
cadre du comité interministériel des
villes
il n'est pas question qu'on laisse
l'entière responsabilité des quartiers
choc à l'état alors que les quartiers
chics serait l'apanage des élus c'est
pour cette raison qu'une des premières
batailles que j'engage et à mon arrivée
au gouvernement et la réforme de la
péréquation en direction des
collectivités locales pour donner aux
villes les moyens de mener cette
politique c'est également le sens de la
réforme de la géographie prioritaire qui
concentre les moyens de l'état en
direction des territoires qui en ont le
plus besoin pour traduire dans les faits
la volonté du président de la république
de tout simplement comme il le dit
donner plus à ceux qui ont moins
c'est cette même recherche d'efficacité
qui nous a mis dans animera pour
élaborer la nouvelle génération des
contrats urbains de cohésion sociale des
dispositifs qui devront être élaborées
avec tous les services de l'état et les
collectivités territoriales autour des
zones urbaines sensibles rénover des
contrats dont je souhaite étendre la
durée pour donner à l'ensemble des
partenaires de la politique de la ville
une vision à moyen terme les quartiers
prioritaires sont donc au coeur du
projet républicain est au coeur de ces
quartiers la jeunesse est l'acteur
principal de la transformation sociale
c'est elle qui changera la donne nous
devons également travailler en
particulier en direction des filles et
des femmes c'est pas étonnant que ce
soit moi qui me dit qu'ils sont souvent
victimes de comportements archaïques
intolérable qui traduisent
l'affaiblissement du projet républicain
je vous rappelle juste les actes
barbares qui existe
encore dans notre pays même si les
médias n'en parlent pas que ce soit les
questions de viol collective que ce soit
aussi la démultiplication du port du
voile est que nous devons absolument
remettre des femmes en temps au centre
des dispositifs elles sont le meilleur
facteur est auteur et acteur part dans
d'intégration est la force motrice du
changement social
c'est pour ça qu'avec nadine morano nous
avons lancé un appel à projet de 30
millions d'euros auprès des associations
et des maires pour favoriser les modes
de garde d'enfants innovants pour
l'emploi des femmes des quartiers
populaires ce qui permettra en réalité
de donner une certaine mobilité à ces
femmes pour qu'elles puissent aller
chercher du travail notamment pour les
filles de moins de 30 ans mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
nous devons donc concentrer tous nos
efforts pour renforcer l'autonomie des
jeunes la véritable autonomie pour les
jeunes des quartiers c'est de pouvoir
accéder à une formation plus un emploi
stable d'être mobile et ambitieux par
rapport à larves alors à venir la
véritable autonomie c'est d'associer
formations et activités de manière
durable
nous ne devons plus laisser les jeunes
libres à eux mêmes dans un total d
evreux mans qui peut conduire au cercle
vicieux de la délinquance j'ai
l'habitude de donner comme métaphore les
jeunes qui tiennent les cages
d'escaliers et qui porte les casquettes
à l'envers
c'est bien simple un jeune doit être son
activité soit en formation c'est tout le
sens de ce que j'ai appelé à une époque
le plan anti glandouille le tonneau mis
des jeunes j'en suis convaincu passe
avant tout par une formation et un
emploi
la dynamique espoir banlieues consiste
justement à cibler ces territoires et
leurs habitants des dispositifs de droit
commun
et quand tous les acteurs s'investissent
ça marche en janvier 2009 près de quatre
cent mille jeunes sont un contrat
d'apprentissage il 180 milles en contrat
de professionnalisation
il est tôt d'insertion dans l'emploi
dans l'emploi après un contrat en
alternance sont bons dames et messieurs
permettez moi de vous présenter quelques
éléments du bilan de la dynamique espoir
banlieues tout simplement dans le
domaine de l'emploi
je vous le disais beaucoup de jeunes des
quartiers veulent créer leur entreprise
c'est pour cela que nous avons initiées
en faveur de la traction d'entreprise
avec des guichet unique d'accompagnement
et des prêts à taux zéro avec laurent
wauquiez nous avons initié un dispositif
novateur
de l'emploi ce que nous avons appelé le
contrat d'autonomie qui propose un
accompagnement renforcé et personnalisé
des jeunes des quartiers prioritaires
l'emploi la formation ou la création
d'entreprise près de 1500 sept jeunes
ont à ce jour signé ce contrat
d'autonomie donc beaucoup plus que ce
que j'ai pu voir dans le certains
chiffres et nous mettrons tout en oeuvre
pour atteindre nos objectifs de 45000
comptera d'ici fin 2011 et assurer une
sortie positive après la période de
coaching nous travaillons en particulier
en partenariat avec les entreprises
signataires de l'engagement national des
entreprises pour l'emploi des jeunes que
nous avons lancé avec christine lagarde
86 entreprises et fédérations
professionnelles se sont déjà engagées à
recruter des jeunes de moins de 26 ans
issus des quartiers prioritaires
en 2008 onze mille cinq cents jeunes ont
déjà signé un cdi ou un cdd de plus de
six mois et 3600 jeunes ont décroché un
stage ou un contrat d'alternance
les entreprises signataires prévoit
d'ores et déjà la création de plus car
de 48 l'emploi d'ici du rap ardent d'ici
2010 il faut que je vous dise que quand
nous avons signé l'engagement avec les
grandes entreprises de notre pays
tout se sont engagés à respecter en
réalité les pourcentages des effectifs
des cadets de l'embauché des jeunes des
quartiers prix populaire donc
normalement les chefs d'entreprises se
sont engagés d'ici trois ans à respecter
donc les engagements qu'ils ont pris
avec nous je remercie évidemment les
chefs d'entreprises qui sont très
satisfaits de cette expérience et qui se
sont engagés comme je viens de le dire à
maintenir leur objectif sur 2009 et 2010
malgré la crise en étant conscients de
leurs responsabilités accrues dans cette
période difficile mais en complément de
ces dispositifs qui ont été consciente
période de croissance je vous le
rappelle nous devons aujourd'hui fléché
au mieux l'ensemble des dispositifs mis
en place par le gouvernement en faveur
de l'emploi pour faire face à la crise
en direction des jeunes des quartiers
je veux parler évidemment vous l'aurez
compris des 380 mille contrats aidés de
la mise en place du rsa
la généralisation du contrat civique
pour les jeunes de 18 à 25 ans
conformément aux souhaits du présente
devant lui
l'extension aussi du contrat de
transition professionnelle et de tous
les effets de la réforme actuelle de la
formation professionnelle aux côtés de
brice hortefeux nous avons fait des
propositions au président de la
république en ce sens notamment ce qui
concerne les contrats aidés
l'intérim le développement des actions
de parrainage de tutorat des jeunes en
entreprise
nous devons évidemment également
réfléchir à la pertinence des contrats
aidés unique pour éviter un empilement
des mesures nous sommes au stade de
réflexion mais peut-être et fethi
effectivement face à la démultiplication
des différents dispositifs
peut-être qu'il nous faut penser à créer
un seul et unique dispositif
ce contre un contrat constituerait une
réponse simple fondée sur le critère des
territoires en difficulté et des
situations individuelles de chômage
bulls avaient la rénovation urbaine a
été placé au coeur du plan de relance
aussi en tant qu instrument efficace de
dynamisation économique des quartiers et
de création d'emplois à travers les
clauses d'insertion qui bénéficie aux
publics les plus en difficulté vivant à
proximité des chantiers
toujours dans le cadre du plan de
relance nous avons développé un
partenariat avec nadine morano et
valérie letard pour orienter les jeunes
des quartiers dans les métiers de
services à la personne qui est un vrai
terreau d'emplois je continuerai aussi
évidemment vous l'aurez compris 1 bat
pour que ce plan de relance bénéficient
en priorité aux jeunes des quartiers
populaires
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs la
crise qui frappe aujourd'hui notre pays
est aussi une opportunité pour aller de
l'avant
elle nous permet aussi de repenser le
fonctionnement de notre économie et de
notre société
je me réjouis donc en particulier de la
prise de conscience des entreprises qui
ont compris que la diversité est là nous
sommes au coeur d'aider certains débats
n'est plus un obstacle mène à tout
social et économique
une force pour répondre à la diversité
des marchés à partir alors ils partir à
leur conquête
j'ai eu l'occasion de m'exprimer sur ce
sujet plusieurs reprises je le répète
avec fermeté je suis totalement opposé
au principe de discrimination positive
lorsque je discute avec les habitants
des quartiers
ils ne réclament pas le droit à la
diversité ou à la différence mais au
contraire un droit à l'égalité
le vrai débat c'est la réduction des
inégalités sociales qui sont encore
criantes et non la promotion de
diversité pour la diversité qui en
réalité pour moi l heure le véritable
défi de notre société c'est de permettre
la promotion des enfants d'ouvriers dans
les entreprises en politique ce qui
entraînera home automatiquement une plus
grande diversité dans la société
mais je pense que les danger est plus
grand encore je suis convaincu que tout
discours qui tend à privilégier des
catégories de population selon des
critères ethniques menace dangereusement
le projet républicain le président de la
république dans son discours prononcé à
l'école polytechnique a fait son choix
quand il dit que c'est par le critère
social qu'il faut prendre le problème
parce que les inégalités sociales
vous l'aurez compris englobe toutes les
autres dans le monde de l'entreprise
je soutiens les mesures incitatives qui
permettent d'accompagner un changement
des mentalités
il existe déjà des mesures plus
contraignantes mais qui ne sont pas
fondées sur une approche ethnique comme
le label de la diversité qui permet de
mesurer le process de l'entreprise en
faveur de toutes les formes de diversité
qu'elle soit liée au sexe à l'âge en
lundi au cap
j'ai également apporter mon soutien au
tour de france en faveur de la charte de
la diversité aux côtés de claude bébéar
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
notre grande priorité de la dynamique
espoir banlieues qui me tient à coeur
c'est l'éducation
c'est pas pour rien qu'il nous faut
aussi parler de l'éducation parce que la
responsabilité de l'action publique et
d'offrir à tous les mêmes chances de
réussir et d'agir sur l'ensemble des
points de fragilité tout au long du
parcours de chacun de l'école maternelle
jusqu'au marché du travail
nous devons veiller à la bonne
articulation de l'emploi avec la
formation et l'éducation
mon objectif en la matière c'est
l'excellence scolaire et la réussite
éducative sur l'année scolaire 2007 2008
le programme de réussite éducative qui
mobilise une enveloppe de 90 millions
d'euros sur les crédits politique de la
ville a permis d'aider individuellement
plus de 130 mille enfants et jeunes des
quartiers populaires des actions de
soutien scolaire pendant les vacances
ont été mis en place dans 200 lycées
généraux technologiques et
professionnels depuis août 2008 des
internats d'excellence ont déjà
accueilli mille deux cent cinquante
jeunes issus des quartiers populaires
qui bénéficient d'un accompagnement
éducatif renforcé
afin de renforcer ce dispositif
notamment pour atteindre l'objectif fixé
par le président de la république
c'est-à-dire 30% d'élèves boursiers en
classes préparatoires nous lançons dans
les prochains jours un plan national sur
les internats d'excellence avec xavier
darcos
nous travaillons notamment à des
propositions pour améliorer
l'encadrement éducatif des internats
l'état également un rôle moteur pour
lever les contraintes foncières qui
permettront la construction la
rénovation d'aeterna en région
parisienne l'objectif est d'accueillir
2500 jeunes pour 2010 et 4000 en 2012
les 100 premières cordées de la réussite
ont été lancées avec valérie pécresse en
2008 et 20 nouvelles cordes et seront
labellisés en 2009 elles permettent ces
cordées de la réussite d'accompagner les
lycéens des quartiers prioritaires à
l'enseignement supérieur d'excellence
des grandes écoles les universités où
une classe préparatoire aux grandes
écoles par des actions de tutorat afin
de renforcer d'accompagner l'entrée dans
le monde du travail
nous devons aussi travailler à une
meilleure orientation des élèves etc de
le plus jeune âge
la pratique du stage permet un jeune en
formation d'acquérir une expérience
professionnelle
si je condamne les pratiques de
certaines entreprises qui exploitent le
filon pour embauche à moindre coût mon
objectif est de lutter contre le chômage
des jeunes cela passe par un
resserrement des liens entre la
formation initiale la formation continue
et les entreprises des banques de stage
ont été mis en place dans 14 académies
pour aider les élèves à trouver un stage
elles seront généralisés à tout le
territoire à l'entrée 2001 pourquoi nous
avons mis en place c'est banque de
stages beaucoup d'entre nous le savent
beaucoup de jeunes qui cherchent un
stage de la troisième pour pouvoir
connaître tout simplement le monde de
l'entreprise bloque tout simplement sur
le fait qu'ils n'ont pas de réseau qui
n'ont pas de moyens ou tout simplement
qu'ils habitent à une mauvaise adresse
et donc du coup quand ils sont face à se
mieux à ces formes de discrimination il
n'arrive pas à trouver le stage donc le
premier le premier la première relation
avec le monde de l'entreprise et souvent
malheureusement une situation de choc et
donc résultat du compte il y à une sorte
de radicalité dans le comportement de
lier avec l'entreprise qui est très mal
vécue dans
les quartiers populaires notamment par
la jeunesse des quartiers populaires moi
j'ai demandé à ce qu'on mette en place
et banque de stages qui permettent en
réalité de fluidifier et de mettre en
situation de stage sans qu'on connaisse
le jeune tout simplement sur les besoins
précis de l'entreprise qui permettent en
réalité de mettre les jeunes en lien
direct avec l'entreprise sans qu on
passe ni par son adresse ni par son nom
ni par son sexe et et autres le contrat
de professionnalisation et
d'apprentissage
la formation en alternance sont les
solutions a développé comme l'a souligné
martin hirsch
comme vous le savez dans son discours
prononcé à saint quentin le président de
la république s'est engagé à développer
l'alternance qui est une des clés de
l'insertion professionnelle en doublant
d'ici 2010 le nombre de jeunes en
formation en alternance
mais quand la première chance n'a pas pu
être saisie
nous devons lutter contre le décrochage
scolaire et de développer les
dispositifs deuxième chance car il est
insupportable que 150 mille jeunes
sortent chaque année du système scolaire
sans aucune qualification ni diplôme
je veux pouvoir donner une deuxième
chance à toute cette jeunesse en 2008
les centres défense deuxième chance de
l'epide établissement public d'insertion
de la défense d'angers la tutelle aux
côtés du ministre au ministère de la
défense et de l'emploi ont accueilli
plus de 2000 jeunes volontaires âgés de
18 à 22 ans sans qualification ni emploi
et un risque de marginalisation dont 30
% issus des quartiers prioritaires
je souhaite atteindre les 50% d'ici 2011
les écoles de la deuxième chance ont
quant à elle accueilli plus de 4700
jeunes sans diplôme ni qualification
dans 43 sites écoles situées dans 25
départements
il faut savoir que plus de 50 % de ces
jeunes proviennent des quartiers
populaires en 2009 nous avons fixé
l'objectif de 6000 élèves grâce à la
création de 20 à 25 sites écoles
supplémentaires répartis dans 40
départements et 18 régions
je m'engage devant vous à réaliser cet
objectif et à aller au delà en 2010 mais
vous aurez bien compris qu'il s'agit en
réalité pour ce qui concerne les écoles
deuxième chance d'avoir un développement
totalement méprisé maîtrisé qu'il s'agit
pas en réalité de développer les écoles
deuxième chance
n'importe quand et n'importe comment
mais bel et bien d'arriver à un
développement maîtrisé une commission de
labellisation des écoles sera mis en
place très prochainement pour garantir
la qualité de la formation conformément
à la charte des réseaux des écoles
deuxième chance je veux faire de l'année
2009 l'année de la deuxième chance et de
la lutte contre le décrochage scolaire
en trouvant des solutions aux
contraintes de financement et
d'implantation france-eire immobilière
afin de multiplier la capacité d'accueil
des jeunes en formation
on connaît tous les problèmes pour le
développement des écoles deuxième chance
les pistes de travail sont là et de
réflexion sont là pour trouver les
solutions
par ailleurs avec xavier darcos nous
avons impulsé une mission pour renforcer
l'ensemble des dispositifs de deuxième
chance en 2009
je souhaiterais mettre en place une
commission pour explorer comment nous
pouvons articulé davantage les
dispositifs de deuxième chance au bassin
d'emploi pour donner des vraies réponses
en termes d'insertion
nous devons également traiter le
problème à la source il repérait le plus
tôt possible les éventuels décrocheurs
au début 2009 nous avons mis en place
dans chacun des 215 quartiers
prioritaires une instance locale de
lutte contre le décrochage scolaire
piloté par le préfet l'inspection
d'académie avec la participation des
délégués du préfet ces conventions
permettre la mise en place d'un tutorat
ou parrainage sociales pour accompagner
individuellement chaque jeune décrocheur
des actions de sensibilisation seront
également menées portail internet et
journée nationale sur la prévention et
la lutte contre le décrochage scolaire
cette catastrophe c'est que nous avons
des gamins l'âge de 14 ans qui sont déjà
en situation de décrochage scolaire que
nous retrouvons par ailleurs comme par
hasard soit dans les cages d'escaliers
soit dans les économies parallèles
donc nous avons un souci majeur c'est de
faire en sorte que nous mettions en
place ce fameux dispositif qui permette
de les remettre dans le cursus scolaire
un bilan d'étape du dispositif local de
prévention du décrochage et
d'accompagnement des jeunes décrocheurs
doit paraître en juillet 2009
dans le même esprit 5000 postes de
médiateurs de réussite scolaire ont été
créés le mois dernier dans les collèges
et lycées en partenariat avec
l'éducation nationale dans le cadre des
contrats aidés
leur rôle est de lutter contre les
premiers signes de l'absentéisme dès la
6e
en tissant des liens avec les familles
et les établissements scolaires pour
anticiper le décrochage
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs oui
nous devons être encore plus offensive
sur la question de l'emploi des jeunes
et multiplièrent rapidement des
dispositifs ciblés et efficaces ces
mesures de sécurisation des parcours eu
de la d'un traitement social du chômage
devant être conçu pour faire face à la
situation actuelle tout en préparant la
sortie de crise par un renforcement des
actions de formation nous devons
soutenir davantage les jeunes des
quartiers pour amortir le choc de la
crise économique pour rebondir et
aborder la sortie de crise dans les
meilleures conditions
l'autonomie des jeunes notamment ceux
des quartiers populaires ne demande qu'à
se réaliser les études montrent que la
volonté de cresson en entreprise est
deux fois plus forte dans les zus que
dans le reste du pays c'est dire si des
énergies sont disponibles pour créer de
la richesse et dynamiser notre économie
une chose est sûre et jeunes des
quartiers qui ont connu des difficultés
pour intriguer le monde du travail de
l'entreprise en tellement 8 de s'en
sortir qu'il en ressorte deux fois à
trois fois plus compétitive c'est en
cela que je suis convaincu que la
relance économique que nous appelons de
nos voeux viendra évidemment voulant
compris aussi des quartiers on devine ou
éventuellement ne viendra pas elle doit
être l'occasion pour nous de modifier
fondamentalement le fonctionnement de
notre société qui produit vous savez
trop d'inégalités de discrimination la
crise ne doit pas être un handicap mais
au contraire une formidable opportunité
pour reconstruire un corriger les
déséquilibres pour transformer les
contraintes en opportunités
vous aurez compris nous ne sommes pas
dans un discours défaitiste mais au
contraire nous sommes dans un discours
totalement optimiste dans le sens où
nous savons que les enjeux qui
concernent notre pays que ce soit d'un
point de vue économique ou social sont
d'abord et avant tout dans nos quartiers
populaires et dans notre capacité nous
les politiques à pouvoir créer ce fameux
contrat de confiance avec la jeunesse
dans tout ça divertit dans toute sa
diversité notamment la jeunesse des
quartiers populaires pour qu'ensemble on
pu construire ce fameux projet
républicain mais ce projet de la france
portée par l'ensemble de ses citoyens
merci merci à vous madame cette affaire
d'état et par l'état bessieux du minck
notre rapporteur
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre
j'aime bien votre discours offensif et
plein d'optimisme savez quand vous dites
qu'il est nécessaire de s'occuper des
jeunes qui sont en difficulté chacun ici
j'en suis intimement persuadé partage ce
choix que que vous faites et on le voit
au sénat lorsque vous dites qu'il ya
beaucoup d'énergie dans ces quartiers on
le voit au sénat alors ne vois pas quoi
c'est non loin dans le quartier mais
quoiqu'il à talents des cités par
exemple on a beaucoup de jeunes qui
remplissent l'hémicycle et là on voit
des jeunes colognac convient de s'en
sortir et cela vous avez raison madame
levis qu'il faut absolument les aider et
je vois que dans le nombre de mesures
que vous avez une humeur et de
descriptif que vous avez fait mais
supprimer un certain nombre de questions
que j'avais prévu vous avez répondu par
anticipation notamment sur le décrochage
scolaire sur l'alternance sur le
dispositif deuxième chance sur la
limitation des écoles tout ça évidemment
dans le bon sens il m'en reste quand
même deux ou trois madame le ministre
question concernant les contrats urbains
de cohésion sociale
donc ce sont les contrats qui ont montré
leur efficacité notamment en ville vie
vacances les ateliers santé ville
est ce que vous envisagez de les
pérenniser ou de les renforcer
ou les deux est ce que vous pourriez
nous rappeler aussi les modalités de la
mise en oeuvre du contrat d'autonomie si
j'ai bien compris ce contrat d'autonomie
vous a un peu déçu si j'ai bien lu c'est
à dire que vous aviez prévu un nombre
plus important et en fin de compte les
chiffres étaient largement tout ce que
vous expliquiez est-ce que
où j'avais fait l'analyse de ce relatif
échec je dis bien très relatif
est ce que vous envisagez de l'adapter
de le modifier ou de le faire évoluer
concernant les emplois jeunes et les
contrats aidés
nous avons évidemment partie auditionné
un certain nombre de personnes ici et
nous nous orientons vers une suggestion
qui seraient des contrats aidés au delà
du privé dans la fonction publique
territoriale dans les collectivités
territoriales nous sommes aperçus qu'à
contrats aidés que nous avions à l'heure
actuelle on pouvait prendre des jeunes
qui étaient en très grande difficulté
qui avaient des difficultés à écrire
compter qu'ils étaient intégrés dans la
collectivité qui est encadrée par les
maîtres d'apprentissage ou en tous les
cas avec des professionnels de grande
qualité
les collectivités les amenons un certain
niveau d'éducation de connaissances pour
les orienter ensuite vers une formation
professionnelle soient pas les chambres
de métiers les chambres des commerces
bien entendu avec un objectif de profit
de professionnalisation et de pouvoir
ensuite les intégrer dans le monde
professionnel donc je voulais savoir si
les contrats aidés que vous avez déjà
beaucoup développé beaucoup favorisé
si vous imaginez d'augmenter le nombre
dans le cadre de ce que je viens de
d'évoquer c'est à dire les contrats
aidés dans les collectivités
territoriales
un autre point concernant les
discriminations est ce que vous pensez
qu'il faut des quotas il faut
contraindre pour la discrimination
positive ou est-ce qu'il faut plutôt
s'orienter vers des mesures incitatives
autre question concernant les stages
j'ai bien compris la banque
que vouliez mettre en place la question
que nous nous posons nous c'est qu'il ya
un certain nombre de stages qui se font
après la formation
qu'est ce que vous en pensez est ce que
ces stages doivent être supprimés est
essentiellement intégré dans le cadre de
la dans le cadre de la formation
enfin j'aurais aimé que vous nous
parliez de l'autonomie de l'allocation
d'autonomie financière des jeunes est ce
que vous pensez c'est quelque chose
d'utile quelque chose qu'il faut
généraliser
est ce que c'est une allocation qui est
liée aux ressources de la famille ou est
ce que c'est une allocation que l'on
doit
donner à chaque jeune voilà quelques
questions je voulais opposer même
ministre
très bien on vous laisse répondre à ces
nombreuses questions de du rapporteur
ensuite interviendront monsieur etienne
monsieur bourquin et madame de montespan
dans une première série alors monsieur
le sénateur sur la question des cuves il
faudrait que je vous dise un peu à peu
près qu'est ce que j'ai voulu faire
quand j'ai intégré le gouvernement pour
penser élaboré la dynamique espoir
banlieues je pense que ce qui est
important et c'est pour ça que ça a pris
du temps dès le départ je voulais
construire une politique de la ville sur
mesure qui colle à la réalité des
besoins des territoires et des gens qui
habitent ces territoires
je n'ai jamais pensé qu'un plan à un
énième plan banlieue avec quatre mesures
est allé répondre à l'ampleur enfin au
besoin justement des quartiers
prioritaires
c'est pour ça que nous avons organisé
d'abord les concertations parce que on
sait tous ici
si les gens ne sont pas acteurs en
réalité ils sont plutôt dans une posture
de subir et donc du coup ils ont une
relation qui est très particulière aux
politiques qu'on peut mettre en place
moi j'ai toujours détesté
on vous le savez je suis issu d'un
quartier en zone urbaine sensible depuis
très longtemps il l'est toujours
d'ailleurs
à mon grand regret j'ai toujours vécu
toutes les politiques ont été mis en
place
d'en haut et on a toujours plus ou moins
subi en réalité des politiques ont été
mis en place se dit pas que ne sont pas
terribles et des choses qui étaient très
bien qu'il faut souligner donc que ce
soit d'ailleurs les gouvernements de
droite ou de gauche il y en a d'autres
qui laissait à désirer mais une chose
est sûre c'est que je pense et je suis
convaincu que
on a raté un rendez vous qui était un
rendez-vous pour moi important c'est à
dire qu'on n'a pas été chercher le
citoyen qui habite ces territoires là
pour que lui participe à la rédaction
justement des politiques que nous devons
mener en sa faveur
et donc nous quand on a organisé les
concertations territoriales ce que
certains appellent cela démocratie de
proximité
mettez-y ce que vous voulez comme
concept l'idée pour moi c'est surtout
que les gens participent et que la
question de la citoyenneté active elle
elle est importante et donc quand on a
fait d organiser des concertations
territoriales on a eu beaucoup de
personnes qui ont participé à
l'élaboration de la dynamique espoir
banlieues je vous dis ça parce que c'est
aussi une manière de casser un sentiment
de désespérance qui existe dans nos
banlieues
c'est aussi une manière de faire en
sorte que quand on s'approprie les
choses et quand on rédige les choses
quand on participe on est beaucoup plus
actif est beaucoup plus productif on
n'est pas dans une posture victimaire
poids de très clair pas dans une posture
de consommateurs vous savez que je suis
pas très attachés en réalité à des
politiques d'assistanat qui perdure dans
le temps je crois que tout ce qui est
tout ce qui peut aider à la réduction
des inégalités territoriales et
participer à des politiques de justice
sociale doivent pouvoir en réalité m au
centre le citoyen mais le citoyen actif
de ces politiques là aussi je suis pas
attaché aux politiques d'assistanat
parce que je crois que c'est ça qui tue
la dignité de l'individu nous l'avons
trop vécu dans les quartiers bon je vous
dis ça pour quoi
parce que nous sommes arrivés à une
période où la philosophie de la
politique de la ville aujourd'hui telle
que je la pensée telle que je la conçois
elle un peu différente de ce qui a été
mis en place
il se trouve que nous avons un rendez
vous législatifs c'est la loi qui nous
le dit les cuves sont à à réviser et
dans le cadre des cucs moi je suis
convaincu d'une chose et c'est aussi le
rapport du sénat il s'est aussi le
rapport de la cour des comptes et et
d'autres rapports qui existent notamment
sur la politique de la ville nous devons
penser une nouvelle une nouvelle forme
de contractualisation qui permettent en
réalité de donner de la visibilité à la
politique de la ville qui l'a petit
permettre de la rendre plus accessible
plus simple et qui permettent surtout
dans
durée d'avoir une certaine cohérence bon
alors oui il y aura une révision donc il
ya la révision des cucs oui ça va être
reconduit je suis favorable à ce que le
temps de la durée des cucs rallonge
parce que je vous rappelle qu'il faut
quand même que ça colle au même titre se
dirait du temps qui est pris pour une
rénovation urbaine ça me paraît logique
en réalité c'est comme ça que je conçois
la politique d'avis que tu voulais
construire à la fois la rénovation
urbaine est à la fois la rénovation
sociale
il faut que ce soit en même temps alors
on on cible à peu près cinq ans pour
rénover un quartier mais je pense que
les contrats urbains de cohésion sociale
doivent aussi perdurer 50 de manière à
ce qu'une certaine cohérence des
politiques entre les deux les deux
partis les deux formes d'intervention
dans les quartiers et dans les cucs et
je pense sincèrement qu'il faut c'est
dans ce sens là que nous irons
il faut que tous les partenaires soit
autour de la table
je vous incite un par exemple ça me
paraît légitime et logique que
l'éducation soit représentée qu'elle ne
soit plus une sorte de nous trompe libre
qui face à certaines ensemble de choses
et vous savez que la kz2 l'édile
éducative est très important dans la
dynamique espoir banlieues et qu'on
parie beaucoup justement sur l'éducation
pour aider à la promotion des enfants
d'ouvriers et c est je pense que
l'éducation a toute sa place sur la
table des cucs parce que je crois que
quand on est plusieurs acteurs à
travailler dans le même sens avec les
mêmes objectifs
ça ne peut pas se concevoir en dehors
des représentants de l'éducation
nationale
voilà on peut pas travailler dispatcher
et s'éclater les uns les autres donc les
cuzon est renouvelé oui vont être un peu
plus nombreux et on va recentrer les
thèmes il nous en profitons aussi parce
que vous le savez nous sommes en pleine
révision de la géographie prioritaire
donc nous avons lancé une livre vert qui
avec le préfet organise la concertation
la plus large possible
il s'agit en réalité de poser le
principe qui a été donnée par le
président de la république de donner
plus au dd plus les territoires en
grande difficulté la réforme de la
géographie telle qu'elle a été lancée
actuellement dans la concertation elle
doit nous donner la méthode la
méthodologie de concertation et ensuite
après on verra comment avec les grands
élus les associations des représentants
d'élus on verra comment la nouvelle
géographie prioritaire se décident en
fonction de ce que nous aurons comme
résultat sur le contrat autonomie 45000
pour
2011 nous maintiendrons les 45000 ce que
je voudrais dire sur les contrats
d'autonomie c'est que c'est une mesure
qui répond totalement à des besoins
précis dans nos quartiers vous savez
qu'il ya ceux qui sont très éloignées de
l'emploi
ceux qui tiennent les cages d'escaliers
ceux qui n'ont pas de formation et c'est
donc là il ya des contrats spécifiques
qui sont portées par la mission locale
encadrés par don par les missiles des
agents de la mission locale qui font un
sacré travail
il ya des jeunes nous le savons tous
qu'ils ont besoin d'un suivi social plus
important les contrats existent donc
c'est bien que ce soit et que la mission
ne peut elle continuer à remplir sa
mission
mais j'ai souhaité mettre en place les
contrats auto nuit parce que nous avons
des jeunes qui n'ont pas de
qualification sont éloignés de l'emploi
sont inscrits nulle part mais en réalité
son besoin tout simplement d'un vrai
travail de coaching de travail sur la
valorisation de l'image de soi et ont
besoin de d'avoir un coup de pouce pour
bénéficier d'une sorte de tremplin qui
les aideront tout de suite à entrer dans
une formation ou une qualification ou un
emploi direct et donc les contrats
autonomie répondants alité un besoin
spécifique à la fois les 80 mille jeunes
qui échappe évidemment tous les
maillages nous savons qu'ils sont ni
inscrits à l'anpe ni aux missions
locales mais aussi à d'autres jeunes qui
sont inscrits en mission locale et qui
ont des grosses difficultés à trouver un
emploi parce que pour des raisons x y
donc le contrat autonomie a eu du mal à
démarrer
pourquoi parce que quand nous avons mis
en place
nous l'avons annoncé au mois de juin et
quand nous avons un seul appel à
la pboc projet oui l'appel à projets non
l'appel à la candidature merci voilà
l'appel à candidatures il y avait un
cahier de charges y avait tout ça donc
il y avait une sorte de circuit
administratif qu'il nous fallait
respecter
moi j'ai eu la prétention de croire
qu'on pouvait faire très vite et en fait
non on a pris un peu trop de temps et ce
qui fait que ça a retardé au démarrage
mais le rythme aujourd'hui est
totalement rempli nous sommes donc comme
je lé précisé tout à l'heure au 31
décembre nous étions à 3080 3 ou 16 mars
nous sommes à plus de 5000 690,8 donc
nous avons atteint le rythme de
croisière la crise n'empêche pas la
signature de contrats d'autonomie
elle a des difficultés sur la sortie
positive
c'est pour ça que nous faisons un
travail spécifique avec l'engagement des
grandes entreprises des petites et
moyennes entreprises aussi qui ont
localement signé parce que c'est là où
il ya le terreau d'emploi qui ont signé
l'engagement avec nous nous mettons en
lien de manière à ce que d'un contrat
autonomie après le coaching après la
mise en situation
on puisse bénéficier d'une sortie
positive vers un emploi donc on
travaille justement la mise en lien sur
le
les contrats aidés le président de la
république l'a annoncé il nous avons sur
les x l'existant il y avait déjà deux
cent trente mille nous avons rajouté
centre cent mille contrats aidés je suis
partagé parce que je moi je me souviens
quand on avait mis en place les emplois
jeunes moi je faisais partie des gens
qui disaient que c'était très bien parce
que ça permettait à des gens de sortir
des statistiques de l'emploi du chômage
pendant des statistiques du chômage etc
mais quand un mode de résultats après
cinq ans c'était difficile pour beaucoup
d'associations par exemple de pérenniser
un emploi ça c'est un vrai souci sur
lesquels nous sommes en train de
travailler
je le vois aussi d'ailleurs par rapport
aux adultes hurley qui sont totalement
dans le cadre de la politique de la
ville sont des contrats aidés aussi qui
bénéficie aux personnes qui ont 30 ans
au bout de deux conventions de de
reconduction de convention de trois ans
beaucoup de femmes puisque c'est souvent
des femmes qui signe ces contrats là et
vous le savez en des difficultés à
trouver un emploi
donc nous sommes en train de réfléchir à
la possibilité qu'en cette période donc
transitoire de pouvoir pérenniser le
temps justement de la crise pour qu'on
est vraiment à la sortie réelle et
concrète et positive des personnes qui
bénéficient de ce type de contrat je dis
que je suis dubitative parce que je
pense qu'en période de crise évidemment
qu'il faut un peu plus de contrats aidés
mais en même temps je ne voudrais pas
casser une certaine dynamique qui existe
malgré tout moi je suis convaincu ce
pour ça que je suis peut être optimiste
outre optimiste pour un certain mais je
suis convaincu que nous ne devons pas
rentrer dans un traitement social du
chômage
je crains que quand nous rentrons dans
ces logiques là nous nous enfermerons
dans quelque chose qui risque en réalité
à terme d'être extrêmement négative que
nous devons mettre en place des contrats
aidés
président de la république l'annoncé il
fera encore d'autres annonces
prochainement le 20 janvier sur ce qui
concerne l'emploi des jeunes ce qui
concerne les contrats aidés je pense
qu'effectivement il faut en avoir
ça permet de sortir de statistiques du
chômage des jeunes mais il faut qu'on
profite et c'est toute l'interrogation
est l'exigence dirais plutôt que j'ai il
faut profiter de ce temps pour que les
jeunes soient formés réellement et
concrètement pour qu'on les prépare
totalement à la sortie de crise moi
quand je vais dans les cités par exemple
je tiens absolument pas un discours je
dirais de on va signer des contrats
aidés dans laquelle vous allez pouvoir
toucher à la fin du mois
tant d'argent etc je leur dis tout
simplement que c'est maintenant qu'il
faut profiter de la situation il faut
que cette crise elles deviennent
opportunités et il faut absolument que
ce discours passé il passe très bien
dans les quartiers moi j'ai pas de souci
particulier
j'ai fait toutes les cités de france et
de navarre ça passe très bien parce que
ils savent aussi ce que ça veut dire que
d'avoir un contrat aidé qui dure trois
ans qui a ensuite renouvelé qui ensuite
encore une troisième fois renouvelée et
au bout de dix ans se définit pas en
fonction de la fonction qu'occupe
dentelle en association ou entreprise
mais tout simplement en fonction du nom
du contrat aidé je pense par exemple aux
deux adultes au relais qui se
définissent en étant comme adulte relais
non pas dans la fonction qu'ils ont dans
leur qu'ils occupent
voilà et je pense que ça c'est
significatif de des dérives qu'il faut
éviter que nous ayons parce que
s'inscrit des gens dans des dents
d'autres logiques et celle ne lisait pas
en réalité être pleinement dans la
situation d'une dynamique qui les
sortiraient justement de deux des
politiques de dead
voilà alors sur le nom sur le quota les
discriminations positives vous
connaissez ma position et ses directeurs
je suis totalement contre les
discriminations positives les politiques
de quotas je pense que c'est extrêmement
dangereux
je le dis parce que c'était valable
avant la crise ça l'est encore plus
aujourd'hui je trouve totalement
irresponsable que de vouloir mettre en
place des politiques de discrimination
positive ou des politiques de quotas par
exemple parce que tout ça en réalité il
faut pas qu'on se raconte l'histoire les
politiques de discrimination positive en
réalité derrière on pense politique de
discrimination positive ethnique
on pense souvent qu'il faut donner plus
aux petits et aux jeunes issus de
l'immigration arabe et aux jeunes issus
de l'immigration subsaharienne
parce qu'ils ont moins etc mais les
petits benoît dans nos quartiers au
moins aussi de la même manière donc je
ne supporterais pas que mon pays mettent
en place des politiques spécifiques pour
les arabes et les blacks sous protêt ce
qu'il faut promouvoir la diversité oui à
de la discrimination c'est une réalité
je suis totalement lucide je m'appelle
fadela donc je sais quand même c'est de
la discrimination
lié à l'origine qui existe mais je
voudrais quand même souligner ici comme
je le fais d'ailleurs un peu partout
aujourd'hui je ne veux pas je ne
voudrais pas qu'on culpabilise les
entreprises qui font un effort
aujourd'hui il ya une dynamique a été
lancé il ya partout des chars de la
diversité qui sont signés il ya
l'engagement des petites et moyennes
entreprises des chefs d'entreprise que
ce soit dans des grosses boîtes ou des
petites boîtes qui s'engagent justement
au beau chez les jeunes des quartiers
populaires
quelle que soit leur origine il faut
avoir une attention particulière pour
ceux qui sont issus de l'immigration
parce que c'est vrai qu'on revient de
loin c'est une réalité mais en même
temps ce qui était valable avant dans
les positions que j'avais elles sont
encore plus valable aujourd'hui parce
que nous sommes en période de crise si
on oublie le petit benoît aujourd'hui
nous risquons si nous favorisons mohamed
et mamadou pour être très clair et nous
oublions le petit benoît nous risquons
en réalité de radicaliser notre société
et nous risquons en termes d'impact
politique de
mais je dirais de re faire ressurgir
l'hydre de la peste qu'est l'extrême
droite et je ne voudrais pas justement
alors que mon pays à travers ce qu'a
fait le président de la république qu'on
soit d'accord ou pas peu importe mais
quand même une des première victoire du
président de la république nicolas
sarkozy s'est d'abord quand même un peu
tué le front national moi je m'en
réjouis parce que on a un peu souffert
dans les années 80 90 donc je me réjouis
de cette de cette victoire et je ne
voudrais pas que même si sa part d'un
sentiment généreux je ne voudrais pas qu
en mettant en place des politiques de
discrimination positive compense
inconsciemment tous ethnique et ben on
se retrouve dans une situation où
l'impact politique et ben l'ail du côté
de l'extrême droite voilà donc je ne
suis pas favorable aux discriminations
positives et à la politique de quotas
c'est pour ça que je ne suis pas
favorable même si je suis pour la mesure
qu'on crée un outil de la mesure de la
diversité je voudrais juste entre
parenthèses vous rappeler qu'il ya déjà
deux outils qui existent
le critère juste pour moi est largement
suffisant comme critère pour même y
compris par exemple mettre dans les
déclarations des ads des chefs
d'entreprise en fin d'année si on
rajoute le critère ça nous donnera une
idée de la promotion de la diversité
sociale et donc aussi pour les gens qui
sont issus de l'immigration
ça nous donnera pas la promotion de la
diversité pour ce qui est des questions
liées au sexe liées à l'orientation
sexuelle etc
mais ça nous donnera une idée de la
promotion de la diversité pour ceux qui
sont issus des zus des enfants
d'ouvriers portrait clair donc on sait
qu'aujourd'hui les enfants d'ouvriers
ont souvent une couleur de peau un peu
plus foncé dans notre pays et donc je
pense que c'est plutôt de ce côté là
qu'il faut se diriger d'ailleurs le
présent dans le public l'a très bien dit
dans son discours à polytechnique
ce qui m'intéresse aujourd'hui c'est que
ce critère là soit connu et reconnu par
tout le monde
c'est pour ça que je ne suis pas
favorable aux statistiques ethniques
si on se dirige dans ce danseur de ce
côté là parce qu'en tout état de cause
les statistiques ethniques d'avants n'a
jamais permis de régler la situation des
blacks aux états unis pour très clair
mais les statistiques ethniques en
réalité amèneront en termes de réponses
politiques en terme d'action à la
politique de quotas auquel je suis
défavorable
moi je suis attaché au projet
républicain même si j'ai conscience si
nous sommes tous lucides qui est des
dysfonctionnements je crois que la
responsabilité des politiques c'est de
faire en sorte que le l'ascenseur social
qu'on re marche il remarche dans le bon
sens pour tous ces enfants d'ouvriers et
très honnêtement je le dis même si des
fois je sais que ça énerve les gens mais
je m'en fous moi de la couleur de peau
ou de l'orientation sexuelle ou quoi que
ce soit de la personne que la république
aide justement à s'en sortir
donc là pour le coup je suis plus
attachée à des politiques et vous
remarquerez une chose c'est que toute la
dynamique tout le programme que nous
avons mis en place en direction des
quartiers populaires la dynamique espoir
banlieues tous les dispositifs que ce
soit en termes d'éducation d'emploi de
formation de culture de sport etc etc
tout tend à promouvoir les enfants
d'ouvriers et ça c'est très important
parce que c'est aussi une manière de
redonner
l'espoir aux gens des quartiers c'est
aussi une manière vous donne un
dispositif qui paie pas de mine comme ça
même si j'ai tapé du poing sur la table
et je pense que c'est opportun de le
faire même si j'ai agacé quelques uns
je pense par exemple au dispositif qui
concerne les délégués du préfet je pense
qu'on a les délégués du préfet qui est
un dispositif qui étaient les délégués
d'état mais j'ai changé non j'ai juste
appelé délégué du préfet vous savez que
certains ont parlé de les territoires
perdus de la république et je voudrais
dire ici c'est pas des vains mots c'est
pas
dir est excessif c'est une réalité
nous avons dans notre pays vraiment des
territoires qui sont perdus totalement
perdu il faut partir à la reconquête de
ces territoires
donc il ya plein de choses qui ont été
faits il faut saluer d'ailleurs la
dynamique a été lancée sous la
responsabilité du président de la
république et du premier ministre tout
temps dans la dynamique espoir banlieues
justement à faire en sorte que on part à
la reconquête de ces territoires
tout tend à faire en sorte que nous
lancions vraiment une dynamique qui
permet la réduction des écarts
territoriaux et donc des inégalités
sociales et tout ça participe en réalité
à faire vivre quoi d'autre que le projet
républicain et les guette délégué du
préfet pour cause ils se tiennent tant à
ce dispositif
parce que dans les quartiers dans les 2
350 quartiers où ils seront présents ils
sont le bras visible gérer physiquement
de du retour de la république et les
habitants des cités
les premières personnes les premiers
interlocuteurs qu'ils auront c'est aussi
je parle à des représentants de l'état
évidemment vous l'aurez compris c'est
les délégués du préfet ce qui revient à
dire que ce qui est important c'est
qu'ils aient une cohérence après au
niveau local donc la refonde les cucs
pour qu'elle soit vraiment pertinente en
terme d'intervention les délégués du
préfet sont les bras armé j'irai de la
mise en place justement de des
politiques en direction des quartiers
prioritaires pour ce qui concerne des
stages moi je suis alors
je pense en réalité je pense que les
stages cette antenne un très très bon
moyen quand il perdure pas dans le temps
de faire connaissance avec le monde de
l'entreprise et apprendre le code de
l'entreprise
mais il faut que ce soit dans un cadre
précis il faut que ce soient codifiées
pour pas qu'il y ait d'abus moi je suis
très attentif aux jeunes qui ont
manifesté ces dernières années qu'ils
portaient des masques blancs
je suis très attentif alors leurs
revendications parce que dans le sens où
je sens bien qu'ils ont tellement envie
de faire des choses qu'ils acceptent de
faire des stages qui sont très longs
dans le temps donc heureusement qu'il ya
une législation qui a rattrapé le coup
et je ne rendais pas compte aux dents
dans les travers alors oui au stage
quand ils sont bien cadré bien codifié
parce qu'ils permettent réellement à des
jeunes d'avoir une connaissance de
l'entreprise d'apprendre les codes
moi j'ai un problème dans les quartiers
sais que vous avez beaucoup de gamins
qui connaissent pas les codes de
l'entreprise
le contrat autonomie pour la première
partie je dirais de du contrat autonomie
ce fameux coaching il permet justement
au delà de la pop du travail sur soi bon
pour bien se présenter pour bien parler
x est un ex tard il s'agit aussi
d'apprendre le code de l'entreprise -
les chefs d'entreprise quand on se rend
compte qu'il me dise tout simplement
vous savez nous on a un problème c'est
que les gamins ne connaissent pas le
fonctionnement de l'entreprise les codes
et c'est a donc du coup très vite ils
sont marginalisés
malgré la bonne volonté du chef de
l'entreprise parle pas de ceux qui
discriminent cela ils ont été montrés du
doigt mais ceux qui font preuve de bonne
volonté
donc oui les stages moi je suis assez
assez favorable pourvu qu'il soit cadré
et et est bien codifiée maintenant sur
l'allocation autonomie des jeunes
il ya deux formes d'autonomie il ya qui
permet d'aider à l'émancipation de
l'individu et à celles qui
malheureusement le mettre en situation
de dépendance je veux qu'on fasse
attention à ça parce que moi je suis
attaché évidemment vous l'aurez compris
est ce que notre jeunesse elle soit
autonome et puis d'ailleurs peu importe
les ressources des parents
je pense que c'est important qu'on donne
les moyens moi je suis très attaché à
l'égalité est donc ce soit un enfant de
bourgeois pour aller très vite moins
d'enfants d'ouvriers
je pense que s'il doit y avoir une
allocation d'autonomie ça doit être pour
les deux parce que les deux méritent
qu'on s'occupe de leur leur émancipation
mais qu'on les aide à devenir des êtres
autonome et pour ça je ne veux pas qu'on
fasse de différence entre les deux types
de deux jeunes dont je suis attaché à
l'autonomie pourvu qu'elle ne soit pas
une autonomie en réalité qui amène à
défendre d'assistanat
voilà c'est ma grande inquiétude et cdd
baquet dans notre pays depuis très très
longtemps je suis attaché à ce que nos
étudiants par exemple soit totalement
libre de pouvoir étudier tranquillement
et sereinement si on veut que demain
notre pays soit compétitif il faut pas
qu'il fasse de trois travaillent en même
temps que les études
donc il faut qu'ils aient les moyens de
pouvoir étudier mais en même temps il
faut aussi que il ya une sorte de
redistribution sais pas comment on peut
dire sa réalité mais une sorte de retour
voilà
il y avait une chose que qui existait je
ne sais pas si ça existe d'ailleurs
encore d'autres ex vérifie le conseil
général à une certaine époque des
collectivités territoriales signé avec
des étudiants aux métiers sociaux des
contrats il payer les études pendant
trois ans et les jeunes qui bénéficie
justement de ce type de contrat pendant
5 ou 10 ans travaillés dans au conseil
général soit l'assistante sociale soit
éducateurs etc ça je trouve que ça c'est
un bon principe c'est un principe qui en
réalité permet de dégager totalement
l'étudiant des problèmes de logement des
problèmes de deux cultures aussi parce
que quand on parle d'autonomie
évidemment il faut parler de tout à la
fois le logement la culture l'accès à la
culture ça coûte cher encore aujourd'hui
même si on a la gratuité grâce à la
ministre de la culture albanel même si
aujourd'hui les moins de 26 ans la
gratuité pour les musées etc
je pense qu'il faut aller encore plus
loin que ça mais et je pense aussi qu'il
faut vraiment qu'il y à un retour voilà
c'est comme une sorte de retour sur
investissement quoi voilà on parie sur
un jeune on paie ses études mais en
contrepartie il faut que lier une
contrepartie
je pense que c'est un bon principe ça
tient bon j'espère il répondu à tous le
voilà même concernant les collectivités
territoriales et contrats aidés et pas
du tout question dans mon esprit dans
notre esprit de traiter le
traitement social du chômage d'accès des
jeunes qui sont tellement éloignés de
l'emploi que les entreprises quand vous
êtes comme nous l'avait indiqué ne vont
pas les embaucher parce que ça ne va pas
marcher
l'idée c'est de donner la possibilité
aux collectivités celles qui veulent
s'engager bien entendu il ya pas de
termes d'obligations en disant voilà il
ya un jeune qui a beaucoup de mal qui
sait à peine lire et écrire on va le
prendre en prendre deux trois ou quatre
l'objectif c'est de les mettre à niveau
de laideur de l'information
professionnelle dans les métiers en ce
sens trop attention il ya tout ce qui
est bâtiment par exemple avec des
maîtres d'apprentissage avec un objectif
bien entendu de les insérer dans la vie
professionnelle en passant dé saper
c'est à dire y'a pas de départ
renouvelables sauf si le jeune loup bleu
loupé le cpsia c'est vraiment objectif
insertion professionnelle il ya un truc
aussi favorable il ya aussi un autre
dispositif qui existe qui est pas mal
mais qu'on ne met pas en avant mais la
vis et les cadets de la république par
exemple ça me rend dispositif qui permet
aux jeunes qui habitent des quartiers
populaires de pouvoir entrer par ce
biais là dans la fonction publique dans
les métiers qui sont des métiers qui
sont un peu décrié dans nos quartiers
mais qui sont indispensables si on parle
de l'ordre républicain émancipateur
merci merci madame roux nous allons
passer à une trois autres questions
monsieur etienne oui merci ma présidente
oui madame la ministre vous n'êtes pas
une adepte de l'orthodoxie de échanges
conventionnel et puisque je pense que
vous permettez est un peu libre dans le
propos qu'on peut tenir
je vous dirais que j'ai vu j'appréciais
déjà la manière dont vous venez de
répondre dans le détail à toutes les
arcanes du développement que monsieur le
rapporteur a évoqué moi je vois dans
votre propos introductif deux grands
volets le premier un relevé terrain dans
lequel vous excellez on voit bien que
vous êtes du cru quelques pas
vous savez ce dont vous parlez vous ai
vu à l'oeuvre d'ailleurs à plusieurs
reprises et notamment à
vitry-le-françois
j'ai apprécié et y'a pas de problème
le diagnostic il est impeccable et on ne
peut qu'y souscrire mêmes et est criant
de vérité et de douleur en même temps
quand vous dites
en deux mots quartier choc problèmes de
jeunesse liés à ces quartiers choc en
france oui notre mission y est
intimement intéressé problème des filles
des femmes dans cette affaire à
résonance ou à forte connotation
culturelle
certainement et puis quand vous concluez
voilà un vivier de forces vives de notre
pays notre république qui est
aujourd'hui faut bien le reconnaître
carrément gâcher compte sur vous pour ça
change alors deuxième volet ce que vous
proposez
ce que vous avez évoquées à on s'attend
à avoir un grand chapitre d'innovation
que dans cette zone de sombres les
obscurités vous projetiez une lumière
innovante qui nous apporte des
perspectives de solutions
transcendantale il y en a certainement
mais je voudrais pas être irrévérencieux
et dire qu'il ya aussi un certain nombre
qui sont beaucoup de sérotype certains
ne sont pas très ancien je vous la corde
d'autres ont déjà un peu d'âge tous ont
en commun jusqu'à présent d'avoir en
grande partie les montrer beaucoup pas
toujours en suis d'accord mais beaucoup
ni l'efficacité pour le moment même dire
ça va venir
on ne demande qu'à vous croire mais
je vais donc pardonné dans l'est et les
contrats d'autonomie dans l'alternance
ça c'est vrai tout ça c'est bien vrai
multiplié par deux en 2010 il n'y a pas
de problème on en rêve tous les soirs
quand on se couche et les écoles de la
deuxième chance
les contrats défense 2e jantes les
contrats aidés en a parlé à bourbon tout
un tas d'éléments que vous intégrer dans
un plan auquel vous avez donné un
vocable extraordinaire qui est
particulièrement séduisant le plan anti
glandouille vous avez raison c'est d'un
plan comme ça qu'on a besoin et on est
d'accord pour que dans le contenu il est
tout ça simplement que en vous écoutant
je me demandais s'il n'y avait pas
peut-être un secteur qui était un peu ce
que tout misé voyez vous avez parlé
beaucoup de de tous ces jeunes et poussé
contrat de tommy d'alternance des cols
de deuxième chance et déjà plus des
gamins
j'ai déjà des gens qui ont 14 15 16 ans
hélas les jeux sont déjà un peu fait et
moi je me disais mais elle va nous
parler de la racine du problème et des
du primaire oui l'école primaire l'école
de la république
l'us armoires la république c'est un six
sept huit ans c'est là que ça se passe
beaucoup l'imprimatur culturel qui va
faire que le jeune va se sentir
appartenir à une collectivité ou pas
vous l'avez certainement présent à
l'esprit et si vous ne l'avez pas
beaucoup développé vous allez
probablement le prendre en compte
là aussi mais je ne vais pas noté
tellement dans le discours que vous
viennent nous dire oui j'ai une remarque
comme ça que josy permis de faire en
forme d'interrogation
et là dessus je me disais que quand vous
avez évoqué monsieur darcos est ce qu'il
développe au niveau du primaire pour là
encore très partiellement notamment au
niveau des cours moyens avec
l'introduction de la donne informatique
de la nouvelle impulsion éducative
socioculturel qu'il semble vouloir
imprimer à la nouvelle donne éducative
pour l'enseignement primaire
je m'interrogeais et je vous interroge
s'il n'y avait pas là pour ces quartiers
sensibles également à marche forcée une
entreprise en termes d' approche
éducative a lancé au niveau
cette fois ci des des jeunes des tout
jeunes ceux qui ont 6 7 ans puis spec
devant tout ça et qui joue du piano
manière extraordinaire il sort ce que
les rennais et bailly n'arrive pas à
comprendre et je me disais qu'il y avait
peut-être place pour que dans votre
ministère soucieux de se donne vous
puissiez participer à cette impulsion
pour une bonne culturel qui va dans
l'air du temps et qui est de nature à
révéler quelque part le potentiel de ces
jeunes qui sont comme les jeunes de
partout et d'ailleurs qui sont ni plus
bête n'est plus intelligent et qui ne
demande qu'à saisir ce qu'on leur offre
alors je voulais vous un temps j'ai jure
c'est cette préoccupation
si vous la partagez si vous la prenez en
compte si vous en faisiez ont même titre
que les écoles de la deuxième chance
les contrats l'autonomie des contrats
aidés tout ça une possibilité
d'inflexion de la maturation éducative
que l'on pouvait impulsé dans ces
quartiers choc qui sont pourtant
d'authentiqués vivier pour les forces
vives de notre pays mais pour lesquelles
je pense qu'il convient d'agir
le au tout début et le mois tardivement
possible
merci monsieur thiel la parole madame et
monsieur burqa va vous poser une
question puis madame de mon test 1er
série de questions on ne rêve pas y'a
que monsieur etienne qui a le droit de
parler aussi longtemps ici vous faites
course
rassurez vous je serai plus coup là mais
miss deux questions la première c'est
sous la géographie que vous avez abordé
tout à l'heure que constate-t-on alors
il ya une grande consultation qu'est
lancée sous l'autorité des préfets et
vous aurez les décisions à prendre
cette consultation fini que
constate-t-on
c'est que les quartiers qui ont été
classés en rue ont eu droit et à des
financements importants dans le bâti
dans le social et on s'aperçoit que des
quartiers qui n'ont pas été dans ces
zonages connaissent une situation plus
que délicate et faisons attention si on
repartait pour plusieurs années dans
cette situation ces quartiers là se
trouve dans une situation de désolation
parce qu'ils n'ont pas accès aux crédits
publics pour la rénovation de l'habitat
pour les extérieurs mais aussi avec les
grands travaux la clause sociale qui
vont avec tout ce que vous avez abordé
tout à l'heure c'est la première
question à géographie faisons attention
parce qu'à la fin la décision sera
lourde d'importance
la deuxième question c'est concernant la
précarité dans la canton nous n'avions
pas la crise deux contrats de travail
sur trois était précaire et quand il ya
les coups d'accordéons de l'industrie et
bien c'est accompagné de contrats
d'intérim massif dans les cités et les
choses lorsque le coup d'accordéon va
dans l'autre sens les renvois
d'intérimaires sont massifs aussi et la
question de la précarité est une
question essentielle sur laquelle il
faut que planches nos sociétés et des
jeunes par exemple comment des quartiers
ont une mission un terrible parfois long
18 mois et sont remerciés du jour au
lendemain avec peu de droit avec peu de
droit et est ce que on avait avancé
l'idée par exemple dans les vers les
usines de sochaux montbéliard où il y à
ces dizaines de milliers de salariés
est ce que le ctp contrat de transition
professionnelle dont ont accès et des
salariés d'entreprises de moins de 1000
salariés
est-ce que les intérimaires pourraient
bénéficier du ctp en ctp ses 90 % du
salaire brut 1
pendant un an et surtout l'accès à
toutes les formations et on pensait que
pour les intérimaires ce serait vraiment
une bonne solution
alors c'est qu'un aspect du problème
mais la précarité est vraiment la
question essentielle parce que tu à
l'heure vous avez abordé toute la série
des dispositifs on s'aperçoit quand il
ya rupture dans le processus d'insertion
faut parfois tout recommencer et l'idée
c'est de garder un processus d'insertion
continue pour qu'il parvienne au cdi à
l'insertion par le travail et
l'insertion sociale qui va avec
et le gros problème est là et je pense
qu'il faut que l'on travaille tous sur
cette question de la précarité qui est
une question essentielle
et dernière chose menace est plus en
forme de deux questions que deux
constats je pense que les choses se sont
avec la crise dégradé extrêmement
sensiblement dans les quartiers
mais vraiment extrêmement sensiblement
et quand je dis on a constaté il fallait
le faire ce qu'on a fait pour le crédit
ce qu'on a fait je pense que pour les
quartiers et les banlieues
il faut qu'on ait un plan d'urgence au
moins aussi fort sans négliger tout ce
qui se fait je travaille comme maire
avec le perreux avec le cucs et tout ce
qui va avec
il faut faire prendre conscience à
toutes celles et ceux qui dirigent que
quand on a vu ce qu'on a pu faire en
quelques semaines pour sauver le crédit
il faut faire la même chose pour les
banlieues sinon sinon on jouera les
pompiers encore une fois et c'est pour
cela qu'il faut que vous ayez les moyens
de le faire et que comment on assure
très vite
l'inclusion de ses quartiers dans la
société française et pour l'instant les
choses sont en train de se décrocher
moi je le constate qu'au maire les
choses se décroche pas les montes
oui je vais j'aurais plusieurs
interventions à faire mais je vais pas
les faire je vais me centrer sur l'école
pour prendre pour poursuivre ce qu'a dit
monsieur etienne aujourd'hui mais vous
le savez vous l'avez dit l'école est
parfois le seul service public qui reste
dans les quartiers populaires pour
reprendre votre expression parce qu'elle
me plaît bien plus tôt que les quartiers
sensibles etc
les quartiers populaires les évaluations
aux connaissances scolaires ont montré
une effroyable corrélation entre les
résultats et les lieux de vie des
enfants je fais pas de dessin en cm2 à
n'ont qu'à la fin de l'école primaire
donc vous avez dit
vous avez repris les propos du président
de la république donner plus à ceux qui
ont moins
qu'est-ce qu'on fait par rapport à
l'école publique dans ces quartiers là
mon collègue a cité le bureau il ya des
expériences tout à fait intéressante qui
se font quid de sape de la pérennité du
pétrin parce qu'on arrive à terme fin
donc est-ce que vous pouvez nous
répondre là dessus je continue à penser
je les observe entre en tant que maire
d'une ville de banlieue de
l'agglomération lyonnaise que la
suppression de la carte scolaire et les
opérations pour permettre à des enfants
d'aller dans d'autres écoles laissent
dans les écoles ceux qui n'ont pas les
moyens d'aller ailleurs
soit parce qu'ils sont déjà en très
grande difficulté scolaire soit parce
qu'ils sont souvent ça se cumulent les
causes et les effets quelle est la cause
quel est l'effet la situation sociale
etc
donc il me semble qu'il faut vraiment
s'interroger sans polémique sur ces
questions là moi je vous interroge aussi
sur quelle place ont fait aux parents
alors je parle pas des jeunes adultes
qui sont victimes là dans la crise de la
perte de l'emploi et là aussi je le
constate
mais plutôt dans le moyen terme qu'est
ce qu'on fait avec les parents de ces
enfants pour qu'ils se sont habilités à
s'occuper de l'éducation de leurs
enfants je le dis comme ça parce que je
le ressens en commère de cette manière
là et puis une dernière question sur les
jeunes diplômés et là je vais parler de
discrimination mais vous le savez bien
madame la ministre que la discrimination
à l'emploi est encore plus forte pour ce
qu'ils sont des plots mais que pour ceux
qui ne le sont pas quand un jeune
mathieu est diplômé quand un jeune
mohamed a le même diplôme
cette jeune mathieu qui trouvent de
l'emploi
et est ce qu'il ne faudrait pas la
prendre des mesures extrêmement fortes
pour permettre l'insertion
professionnelle rapide de ses diplômés
parce que c'est l'exemple qu'il donne
vous le savez bien c'est l'exemple
qu'ils ou elles un garçon et fille et je
pense aux filles aussi qu'il est qu'elle
donne dans les quartiers pour leur petit
frère enfin qui
quelle que soit la situation je crois
qu'il y a là aussi une urgence et et
peut-être à mobiliser les entreprises
sur cette question là madame la ministre
vous laisse répondre sur nous
intéresserons l'audition de fadela amara
tout de suite le journal de 18 heures
présenté par michel grossiord
bonsoir à tous bon soir delphine girard
au sommaire du 18h de public sénat les
salariés de l'équipementier heuliez
devront attendre jusqu'à demain matin
pour être fixés sur leur avenir
le tribunal de commerce report de 24
heures sa décision sur un éventuel
redressement judiciaire de l'entreprise
qui défend son modèle de voiture
électrique
quel avenir pour cette alternative au
moteur à explosion des spécialistes en
débattront au cours de cette édition aux
états unis barack obama prévient que la
restructuration de l'industrie
automobile imposera des choix
impopulaires
le cash total des ports de
boulogne-sur-mer et de calais par les
pêcheurs ils réclament des augmentations
de leurs quotas
des dizaines de milliers de fillettes et
de jeunes femmes vivant en france sous
la menace de pratiques barbares
une campagne d'information leur est
destiné mutilations sexuelles mariages
forcés lentement donc d'une campagne
nationale d'information parmi nos
invités ce soir noté le jean pierre
raffarin sera avec nous dans une dizaine
de minutes 18h45 jean luc mélenchon sera
l'invité que face à nous ségolène royal
était aujourd'hui à la tête de la
manifestation en soutien à l'entreprise
heuliez s'est passé à niort
oui alors les 1000 salariés de
l'équipementier automobile menacé de
licenciement devront encore attendre le
tribunal de commerce de niort a reporté
sa décision à demain 11h toutes les
parties s'accordent cependant à demander
un redressement judiciaire avec une
période d'observation le temps de
trouver de nouveaux investisseurs ce
matin les salariés ont défilé dans les
rues de niort pour marquer leur
détermination à sauver une entreprise
selon eux viable
le récit de cette journée avec olivier
audemar ce devait être le jour j pour
les salariés de liège réunis ce matin
devant le tribunal de commerce de niort
ils manifestaient pour montrer leur
détermination à sauver une entreprise
viable
aujourd'hui on a plus d'espoirs que de
craintes ont à dire
on espère que qui est politisation
judiciaire de seulement redressement
mais les salariés devront encore
attendre après le report de la décision
du tribunal en fin d'après midi à
l'issue d'une audience d'une heure et
demie les syndicats ont toutefois
indiqué que toutes les parties étaient
d'accord pour demander un redressement
judiciaire
parmi les raisons d'espérer la décision
de l'état d'injecter 10 millions d'euros
minimum via le fonds stratégique
d'investissement
la région poitou charentes dirigée par
ségolène royal a mis quant à elle 5
millions sur la table
la présidente du conseil régional
présente en cortège a tenu à mettre en
avant la viabilité du nouveau projet de
liège
en plus aujourd'hui nous avons des
carnets de commandes pleins puisque nous
avons déjà quatre mille commandes de
voitures électriques et que personne ne
comprendrait que cette industrie soit
sacrifiée le principal enjeu reste de
savoir si le redressement sera assortie
d'une période d'observation
indispensable à la survie l'entreprise
pour pouvoir trouver des partenaires et
des capitaux supplémentaires
la décision du tribunal est attendue
demain à 11 heures
et puis les pêcheurs ont taquiné entamé
cet après-midi un blocage total des
ports de calais boulogne-sur-mer et de
dunkerque
plus de 500 pêcheurs sont en grève soit
la totalité de la flottille du nord il
souhaite obtenir une augmentation des
quotas de pêche et la petite élise
enlevée par sa mère est rentrée
aujourd'hui en france avec son père dans
une interview au parisien
la secrétaire d'état nadine morano
annonce que la signature des deux
parents sera à présent obligatoire pour
une sortie du territoire ou pour
l'obtention d'un passeport pour un
enfant
valérie létard est en campagne contre
les excisions et les mariages forcés en
france oui alors il y aurait 1 chaque
année en france 70 milles adolescente
menacées de mariage forcé et 55 mille
cas d'excision pour lutter contre ces
violences faites aux femmes
la secrétaire d'état à la solidarité
lance une campagne de sensibilisation
car si la loi punit ces pratiques
les autorités doivent faire face au
manque d'informations sur ces sujets
encore tabous
le reportage de thomas carré tira
aux côtés de valérie létard khady koïta
cette sénégalaise a été victimes d'une
excision alors qu'elle avait sept ans
après des années passées à souffrir en
silence
elle est devenue l'une des pionnières du
combat contre les mutilations sexuelles
féminines
petit à petit je me suis mise à me poser
des questions et à avoir plus de reuil
l'intérieur de moi-même et ben j'ai
commencé à me rebeller
ça a pris la forme de la violence
verbale puis physique après ç'a pris la
forme de baies de partir de quitter tous
de partir de prendre mes enfants et de
mana les deux sets de 7 familles de
cette maison conjugale
et puis petit à petit de me reconstruire
et aider les autres tours doma de se
reconstruire
six jeunes filles ont rarement
conscience de leur statut de victimes la
faute au manque d'information et au
poids des traditions
le gouvernement lance donc une vaste
campagne de communication contre les
mariages forcés et les mutilations
sexuelles
cent mille brochures comme celles ci
vont être distribués dans les lieux
publics
rappel de la loi contacts utiles des
informations simples et précises pour un
public qui ne connaît pas toujours ses
droits aujourd'hui il faut là aussi
comme pour les violences conjugales
briser le silence supprimé toutes ces
idées reçues sur les questions de
coutume ou de religion qui imposerait
tout cela c'est faux et surtout dire aux
familles qui soutiennent cela
qu'aujourd'hui la loi les punisse
sévèrement si elle s'engage dans ces
voies en la matière l'arsenal juridique
français est l'un des plus répressifs
d'europe pour les mutilations sexuelles
par exemple les parents de la victime
risque jusqu'à 20 ans de réclusion
criminelle
barack obama fait la une de ses
promesses électorales a décidé de lever
partiellement l'embargo sur cuba
oui alors c'était dans les faits une
promesse du candidat barack obama les
cubains expatriés vont désormais pouvoir
se rendre dans l'île et transférer des
fonds sans restriction cette décision
survient à quelques jours du sommet des
amériques qui doit se tenir en fin de
semaine à trinidad
un véritable changement de cap dans la
politique extérieure des états unis mais
peut-être aussi un profond
bouleversement pour l'économie cubaine
après des années d'un embargo très
restrictif deborah jenny smadja et anne
louise de rohan
certains parlent d'une détente entre les
etats-unis et cuba barack obama a en
effet donné hier une série de mesures en
faveur de lille désormais les américains
d'origine cubaine concernés seraient
près d'un million et demi moore ont
voyagé plus bas et envoyer de l'argent à
leurs proches fournil sans aucune
mutation
mais pour l'historien pierre rigoulot
cela ne changera pas l'économie cubaine
en profondeur doit y avoir quelques
changements mais vous savez on est
probablement en ce qui concerne cuba et
sur le plan politique à la veille de
deux transformations plus importante
simplement c'est à fausser
transformation elles vont venir des
cubains et pas des américains selon
pierre rigoulot des transferts massifs
d'argent sur l'île risquerait de
provoquer une inégalité croissante parmi
les familles cubaines et ne rétablira
pas une économie désastreuse avec un
salaire moyen de 15 euros par mois
environ 200000 cuba cette île chaque
année 15 % de la population auraient
déjà quitté l'île la plupart d'entre
elles installé aux états unis pour
autant l'embargo commercial des côtés en
62 reste en vigueur à cuba le vice
président joe biden a réaffirmé
récemment que washington attendait un
engagement ferme du régime en faveur des
droits de l'homme avant une éventuelle
levée de l'embargo
fidel castro lui dit refusé l'aumône et
continue d'exiger la fin du blocus à
cuba le réchauffement des relations
entre la france et la chine
oui alors que la chine s'apprête à
célébrer les 20 ans des dramatiques
événements de tiananmen et que les
autorités promettent une liberté
d'expression accrue et un plan d'action
pour les droits de l'homme
jean pierre raffarin sera un autre
invité dans quelques instants
le sénateur de la vienne revient d'un
voyage en chine l'occasion pour nous de
faire un point sur les relations entre
ces deux pays
fabrice cloux la brouille aura duré plus
d'un an avec comme point d'orgue
l'épisode mouvementé de la flamme
olympique à paris où la rencontre entre
nicolas sarkozy et le dalaï lama en
décembre dernier quasiment au point mort
les relations officielles franco
chinoises sont relancés depuis le récent
g20 et l'intérêt n'est pas seulement
économique
c'est important parce que tout
simplement déjà les deux puissances ont
toutes les deux membres permanents du
conseil de sécurité
il ya toute une série de dossiers sur
lesquels il faut un minimum coopérer
c'est important pour la france aussi
parce que vous parlez doghri conomique
la france la chine est théoriquement un
grand marché par un très grand marché
pour la france pour le moment mais enfin
il ya du potentiel et pour certaines
entreprises c'est très important
la chine a annoncé un plan de relance de
455 milliards d'euros
de quoi intéresser les 1400 entreprises
françaises installées là bas
de quoi aussi motivé pékin pour ce
rapprochement franco chinois détient
beaucoup aimé dire que nous avions
énormément besoin de la chine et ce qui
est vrai je crois que la chine a aussi
besoin du monde extérieur de plus en
plus l'europe pour la chine l'union
européenne dans son ensemble est le
premier marché des produits chinois dont
on voit aujourd'hui qu'il soit
absolument essentielle pour la reprise
économique en chine même la france parmi
ces pays est un acteur important c'est
un acteur important en terme de
transfert de technologie également au
delà des échanges économiques de grands
dossiers internationaux attendent
français et chinois
un rapprochement durable entre les deux
pays pourrait ainsi faire avancer les
questions environnementales ou l'aide
aux pays africains
les obsèques de rené monory ancien
président du sénat de 1992 à 1998 figure
de la vème république auront lieu jeudi
à 11h dans la vienne à loudun sa ville
natale
tout le week-end les hommages se sont
succédé gérard larcher saluant un homme
résolument tourné vers l'avenir un
visionnaire d'une curiosité insatiable
merci delphine girard la suite du 18
heures tout de suite notre invité
jean-pierre raffarin
monsieur le premier ministre bonsoir
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous vous
aviez attiré l'attention de nicolas
sarkozy il ya quelques semaines sur le
dossier heuliez le tribunal de commerce
de niort va finalement rendre son avis
demain sur un redressement judiciaire
que tout le monde attend est ce que ce
retard peut être interprété avec estime
isme selon vous non pas forcément je
pense que une solution se dessine pour
la partie véhicules électriques mais qui
est une partie seulement de l'entreprise
heuliez il y à toute la carrosserie il
ya les presses il ya beaucoup d'autres
activités au total plus de 1000
personnes
très franchement je trouve que les
constructeurs automobiles français ne
font pas ce qu'ils devraient faire
vis-à-vis de liège je trouve tout à fait
dommageable que ces entreprises
nationales soit aidée massivement et
qu'on laisse des sous traitants des
équipementiers dans cette situation
c'est une usine à la campagne liesse qui
te tient beaucoup de brevets qui fait
vivre beaucoup d'activités avec une main
d'oeuvre de qualité qui a aujourd'hui
depuis plus de dix ans innover en
matière de véhicules électriques
il y à d'autres perspectives automobiles
qui pourraient être intéressés en termes
de sous traitance nos grands
constructeurs
j'espère que d'ici la fin des périodes
qui vont être dessinée d'action on
puisse trouver une solution les grands
constructeurs ne peuvent pas être
indifférents au sort des équipementiers
dont ils ont profité pendant très
longtemps et vous les appelez donc ce
soir ses grands constructeurs français à
participer à la recapitalisation de
liège en tout cas de participer sous
quelque forme que ce soit mais par
exemple en tenant du travail en donnant
de la sous traitance à faire en sorte
que par un effort de solidarité
nationale
il s'implique là où il ya des
compétences il ya où il ya des
équipements là où il ya des talents leur
indifférence de mon point de vue serait
coupable
est ce que le volontarisme
était le fait des pouvoirs publics dans
cette affaire-là est ce que vous estimez
par exemple que le gouvernement s'est
impliqué suffisamment toi tout effacé
massivement je peux même vous dire que
j'ai trouvé luc chatel remarquable sur
le dossier
il est allé sur place il a amené
beaucoup de réunions il ya trouvé une
solution pour la partie véhicules
électriques il faut aller au delà
maintenant sur la carrosserie et les
autres formes d'équipement et qui sont
fournies par heuliez
mais je pense que luc chatel a fait
preuve de beaucoup de capacités sur ce
dossier mais naturellement il est clair
que il ne peut pas agir tout seul
des ex hôtel vous pourriez aussi citer
ségolène royal 1 qui était on l'a vu
tout à l'heure à la tête de la
manifestation à niort aujourd'hui 10
millions d'euros de l'état 5 millions du
conseil régional c'est un schéma idéal
je trouve que pour le moment où madame
royal fait beaucoup de politiques avec
ce dossier et donc je pense qu'un peu de
discrétion et le travail en profondeur
plutôt que de l'agitation
telles que les choses sont menées
aujourd'hui ça ne paraît pas être la
meilleure manière de pouvoir rassembler
autour de ce dossier
tout ce qui pourrait ou au sein d'un
consortium du véhicule électrique être
rassemblés aujourd'hui à cerizay dans
les deux sèvres peu d'agitation
politique je trouve que le responsable
politique
il est d'être aux manettes des solutions
et pendant les démonstrations dans la
rue mais là quand même il y à un cheikh
du conseil régional on annonce 5
millions d'euros on annonce également
des commandes de ce fameux véhicule
électrique le freiner c'est moi qui ai
lancé le véhicule électrique alliel ça
fait dix ans que lles fait des
prototypes ça fait dix ans que l'ia est
capable aujourd'hui de sortir est des
véhicules électriques mais vous aurez un
débat tout à l'heure et vous verrez que
toute la difficulté c'est d'assurer
durablement des commandes et c'est pas
parce que on peut assurer aujourd'hui
grâce à la mobilisation des bips 600
commandes qu'on peut assurer un
développement durable du véhicule
électrique
tout le problème est de créer le marché
et donc il ya tout un travail qui doit
être fait et ce travail là ne peut se
faire qu'avec des industriels et pas
seulement des pouvoirs publics qu'ils
soient nationaux ou locaux alors on
verra effectivement quelle est la
crédibilité de ce projet quelle est
l'alternative effectivement viable au
moteur à essence jean pierre raffarin
vous
revenez de chine perry et pékin se sont
réconciliés en marge du récent sommet du
g20 qu'attendez-vous de cette
réconciliation aujourd'hui je pense
qu'elle était nécessaire parce que dans
la situation de crise internationale est
la chine joue un rôle économique mais un
rôle politique majeure et donc qu'il est
très important que la france puisse
notamment conseil de sécurité comme le
disait notre expert valérie niquet tout
à l'heure au conseil de sécurité nous
avons besoin de la chine sur des
dossiers importants je pense à la corée
du nord
on a besoin de la puissance de la chine
et qui a fait des pressions sur la corée
du nord et la chine aujourd'hui sans
doute le pays le mieux placé pour éviter
une profanation nucléaire dans cette
partie du monde donc il ya vraiment un
travail très important qui est menée au
conseil de sécurité
je pense qu'on a besoin de la chine sur
le plan politique je pense évidemment
qu'on a besoin de la chine sur le plan
économique ou sera la croissance en 2009
en 2010 aux états unis en europe la
croissance sera en asie et
principalement au chili et même si la
croissance est sans doute de moitié
inférieure à celle qu'elle fut l'année
dernière la croissance chinoise est très
importante et les chinois ont investi
beaucoup d'argent
y compris dans la sécurité sociale de
manière à ce qu'il y ait moins d'epargne
parce qu'aujourd'hui les chinois
épargnent parce qu'ils ont peur de
l'avenir et donc de manière à ce qu'ils
consomment plus le gouvernement apporte
un certain nombre de sécurité je pense
que nous avons besoin de la croissance
chinoise et j'ai obtenu une bonne
nouvelle puisque vous le savez au mois
de février une mission d'achat est venue
en europe elle est allée en allemagne l
italie en espagne et italie au royaume
uni elle n'est pas venue en france et
bien elle va venir et dans quelques
semaines et quelques mois en france et
le total des achats qui ont été faits à
l'époque était de 13 milliards de
dollars c'est peut-être au mois de
février donc il y a une capacité là pour
les entreprises françaises de participer
à la croissance chinoise et donc de
défendre l'emploi en france de manière
très significatif et ça c'est important
alors peut-être des dividendes
économiques donc la suite c'est je le
vends réconciliation reste qu'il n'ya
pas un prix politique à payer pour paris
est ce qu'il ya eu un revirement de
paris par exemple qui avait milité on
s'en souvient pour un dialogue entre les
autorités chinoises et le dalaï lama est
bien coûter ce dialogue existe en tout
cas paris a maintenu la position qui
était celle du général de gaulle depuis
1964 paris a précisé cette position je
pense qu'il était nécessaire de
clarifier clairement le fait avec eux
que nous sommes dans une situation où on
respecte l'unité de la chine et que
d'autre part on applique la charte des
nations unies qui parlent de droit de
non-ingérence et donc nous appliquons
ces principes des nations unies dont
hong kong revenant à la position
historique de la france et de ce point
de vue là cette clarification est utile
il faudrait peut-être la poursuivre
parce que rama yade explique dans
libération ce matin que le dalaï lama
reste bienvenue en france 1
alors que les autorités chinoises elle
estime que l'accord interdit toute
rencontre d'écouté en est-il selon vous
écoutez lien communiqué qui a été écrit
noir sur blanc par le ministère des
affaires étrangères madame rama yade
fait partie du ministère des affaires
étrangères je les invite donc à lire les
communiqués que publie son ministère en
contre ou pas est-ce que ce sera
possible encore à l'avenir avec la
marque le pas venu maman francs le texte
n'est pas sur ce sujet là ne prend pas
position il rappelle la position qui
était demandé par les chinois quelle est
la position de la france sur l'unité de
la chine
la position de la france est de
respecter la souveraineté de la chine et
de respecter l'unité de la ji est d'être
contre l'indépendance du tibet et contre
elle récuse sous toute forme que ce soit
le soutien à l'indépendance du tibet
donc on ne peut pas je pense pour un
responsable de l'état français
aujourd'hui participer à une initiative
qui apparaîtrait comme un soutien à
l'indépendance du tibet le texte est
clair et c'est un chef qui vient du
ministère des affaires étrangères donc
il doit s'appliquer aux ministres il me
semble très bien voilà qui éclaire pékin
en tout cas annoncé un plan d'action
pour les droits de l'homme ça à la
veille du 20e anniversaire du
déclenchement des des tristes événements
de tiananmen liberté d'expression a cru
meilleure protection légale est ce qu'on
peut croire qu'un écouter n'ayez pas une
vision de la chine quitté vision arcueil
j'ai rencontré les jeunes de sup de co
reims race management school
ils sont plusieurs dizaines en chine
actuellement j'ai passé une soirée avec
eux savez vous que plus de 60 % d'entre
eux va le rester en chine
si le pays était aussi détestable on
veut bien le dire en occident croyez
vous que ces jeunes voudraient faire
leur carrière aujourd'hui en chine
ils sont à plus de 60 % à vouloir rester
après trois ans d'études en chine faire
leur carrière en chine
et quand vous voyez aujourd'hui le nom
de chinois qui sont sortis de la
pauvreté
moi je suis allé en chine pour la
première fois en 1976
j'ai vu des centaines de millions de
chinois en 30 ans qui ont quitté la
famine qui ont quitté la misère alors
bien sûr qu'il ya beaucoup de choses à
faire dans leur pays en matière de
libertés publiques en matière de
libertés publiques
donc comme l'autre comme dans d'autres
pays comme dans le nôtre dans nos
prisons vous savez on a beaucoup de
choses aussi qui sont à faire donc à
force de donner des leçons à tout le
monde on perd en crédibilité donc
faisons en sorte que on fond de l'amitié
sur la réciprocité du respect à notre
politique française jean pierre raffarin
les rumeurs de remaniement vont bon
train vous avez vu c'était la manchette
du figaro ce matin on voit même
désormais que des ministres réclament
une promotion nadine morano
christine boutin un commentaire sur ses
ambitions décomplexées désormais de
certains ministres on ne fait pas un
gouvernement à la corbeille et je ne
crois que nous avons pas un système de
nominations gouvernementales
aujourd'hui qui se fait aux enchères
donc j'invite les uns et les autres à ed
plus modérés dans leurs ambitions
je pense d'ailleurs qu'en faisant de la
sorte ils ne serviront leurs causeries
alors on ne se baigne pas deux fois dans
le même fleuve c'est ce que vous avez
dit que vous étiez interrogé sur votre
éventuel retour au gouvernement mais
alain juppé a été premier ministre
ministre lui il est candidat pour
revenir vous c'est un refus définitif et
moi je n'ai pas du tout cette intention
gens respectent la position d'alain
juppé alain juppé a de grands talents
la france peut tout à fait avoir besoin
de lui il s'est s'impliqué sur des
grands dossiers
donc je trouverais ça qu'une très bonne
idée alain juppé puisse revenir au
gouvernement en ce qui me concerne je
n'y suis pas favorable
d'accord le remaniement va s'imposer
dans la période charnière des
européennes est ce qu'il doit inclure le
premier ministre
c'est au président de la république de
descendre à bien je pense que nous
allons avoir un remaniement relativement
important mais il me semble que le
changement de premier ministre s'il doit
y avoir un changement de premier
ministre devrait se faire plus tard
quand on sera au sortir de la crise
quand on y verra plus clair sur la
situation internationale et donc c'est
plutôt dans la deuxième moitié du
quinquennat que l'on peut envisager
d'avoir une relance du quinquennat avec
le même premier ministre ou avec un
autre premier ministre
mais pour le moment je ne ferai pas ce
pronostic vous savez c'est pas moi qui
décide bien sûr dernier point peut-être
une information qui pourra vous faire
sourire jean-pierre raffarin jacques
chirac arrive pour la première fois en
tête du classement des personnalités
classement de l'ifop pour paris match
avec 74% d'opinions positives je précise
cette fois devant rama yade est bien
coté je suis très heureux ça faire
plaisir à nos amis chinois
merci jean pierre raffarin nous revenons
maintenant sur l'avenir de liège le
tribunal donc de commerce de niort se
prononcera demain et sur la voiture
électrique son essor pourrait passer par
la location de courte durée dans les
villes alain ricci
on connaît le vélib ce vélo que l'on
peux t'emprunter 24 heures sur 24 7
jours sur 7 sans réservation et sans
leur déposées à l'endroit où on l'a pris
voici sa petite soeur l'autolib comme
son nom l'indiqué c'est une voiture que
l'on pourrait ainsi emprunter c'est pour
des parcours limitée avec un temps de
recharge qui peut être effectuée la nuit
ou ou en journée mais où la voiture
restera sur place
effectivement ça peut être bien prêt
faut voir les modalités
combien ça va coûter
quel sera le prix pour le particulier et
pour la collectivité
deux mille voitures à paris et 2000 en
banlieue devrait ainsi être mise à
disposition des franciliens des voitures
propres selon le cahier des charges ce
qui favoriserait deux constructeurs qui
ont modélisé des voitures 100%
électriques bolloré avec sa bluecar et
heuliez avec ça flingue lee pour
l'instant il n'y a rien de concret parce
que ça nécessite beaucoup
d'investissement et puis shawky une
demande qui soit suffisamment forte pour
que le marché soit rentable d'autres
véhicules moins chers ont investi le
marché la voiture hybride moitié
électrique moitié thermique comme la
toyota prius la honda insight ou la
lexus et la voiture électrique avec un
moteur thermique générateur
d'électricité comme la chevrolet volt ou
le pen en perd a de toute façon pas de
débouchés à paris pour la voiture 100%
électrique
en tout cas pour l'instant la voiture en
libre-service et retarder le conseil
régional a refusé de financer le projet
à hauteur de 10 millions d'euros
alors la voiture électrique quel avenir
nous en parlons maintenant avec nos
invités michael mariemont soir où les
secrétaire national adjoint des verts
jean syrota expert en énergie et auteur
d'un rapport
longtemps tenus secrets sur l'automobile
du futur il vient d'être dévoilée
discrètement vous en parlerez et
françois roudier qui le porte parole des
constructeurs d'automobiles français etc
ont été épinglés il ya un instant vous
avez peut-être entendu jean pierre
raffarin ils vous reprochent vous les
constructeurs français de ne pas vous
impliquer suffisamment bien dans le
choix électrique notamment dans le
dossier heuliez qui nous renier et à
nous adhérons d'ailleurs quasi vous
payer quand est ce que les grands
constructeurs pourraient s'appliquer
plus sa part des commandes des garanties
ou même une montée dans le capital de
liège l'ours est un cas spécifique
heuliez si vous voulez c'est un
constructeur c'est un équipementier 1 il
faut être bien que ces constructeurs
carrossiers et en europe en asie
plusieurs oliech karman pininfarina qui
faisait les petites séries et des
petites séries de coupé-cabriolet en
particulier convaincante quand c est qu
pétroliers ont bien fonctionné on a pu
les mettre dans des usines et ils ont
perdu une partie de leur métier
donc il cherche à se diversifier vers
d'autres activités de l'électrique et de
l'équipementier
traditionnellement ils sont un peu en
avance sur vous d'ailleurs un sur les
constructeurs va tomber mais je veux
dire ils ont choisi ils sont tout vote
sur les crédits sont constructeurs ils
ont eu une vers une version comme les
deux autres adhérents psa et renault
alors jean syrota dites nous la vérité
sur votre rapport est ce qu'il contient
il a été longtemps gardé sous le
boisseau
dans ce rapport vous êtes quand même
critique sur cette voiture du futur
électrique
il reconnaît certes vous reconnaissez
certains avantages mais certaines
limites aussi ciblé dans ce rapport ce
qu'on a d'abord regardé c'est quelle est
la forme d'énergie qui est la plus
propice pour faire marché des mobiles
des véhicules en particulier
alors là il ya pas photo c'est le
carburant actuel qui est de loin le plus
efficace et il est commode pour son
transfert s'il voulait pour un même kg 2
vous pouvez mettre 45 soit 50 fois plus
d'énergie quand c'est du lait sens que
quand c'est de l'électricité en incluant
le poids des batteries pour le transfert
d'énergie quand vous transférez
d'électricité avec une prise électrique
à 220 volts bien vous d'en transférer
pendant le même temps 400 500 fois moins
que quand vous transférez de du
carburant à la pompe à essence autre
conclusion donc la conclusion d'abord
c'était que le véhicule thermique il a
des gros avantages le carburant peut
être fait d'ailleurs avec autre chose
que du pétrole il peut être fait avec da
biomasse avec la du gaz du charbon si on
sait capter le co2 mais il est capable
de faire des progrès considérables
encore on doit pouvoir diminuer de
moitié la consommation d'un avait un
véhicule thermique
c'est un point important alors après on
regarde quels sont les inconvénients des
véhicules thermiques l'inconvénient
principal c'est que ils polluent dans
les centres villes
il engendre du bruit etc et puis donc
l'alternative pour nous on a évacué
l'hydrogène le l'air comprimé le gaz
naturel s'est il reste électricité qui
répond bien à la question quand les
déplacements urbains pour les
déplacements urbains on peut lui pas sur
place et ça fait moins de bruit mais la
contrepartie c'est que il faut se payer
les battre ici je fais dire il faut se
les payer parce que ça coûte très cher
et puis ensuite il faut se les payer
parce que les performances des batteries
sont encore très insuffisante et par
conséquent vous avez un problème
d'autonomie de dégradation des batteries
au fur et à mesure pour les recharges
même dans certains cas on l'a vu sur des
batteries d'ordinateurs il ya des
incendies
donc c'est pas encore fiable la
longévité de la garantie et puis ça
coûterait très cher alors mais quel mari
est ce que la capter ces crédits quand
même la conclusion quand même vrai pour
le véhicule d'avenir puisqu'il faut
peut-être de l'écrit ci dans les
centres-villes et maya de véhicules
hybrides d'accord sur les critiques
formulées à parfaire intéressant dans
dans le propos de jean syrota c'est
qu'effectivement ça a le mérite de nous
montrer qu'il ya pas de solution miracle
c'est à dire qu on est confronté tous
ensemble les sociétés contemporaines
sont confrontés un défi la mobilité un
défi l'énergie un défi du climat
il n'y a pas de solution miracle c'est à
dire qu'on ne va pas magiquement et
j'allais presque dire sans difficulté
sans douleur remplacer la voiture
thermique qui roule au pétrole par une
autre voiture un autre modèle unique qui
résoudrait tous les problèmes pendant
combien de temps pour ça je pense que
c'est parce que je suis en train de vous
dire c'est que ça n'arrivera pas grâce à
tout simplement c'est pas une question
que jamais c'est une question de regard
sur tous ces problèmes
aujourd'hui on a un modèle unique qui
est celui de la voiture individuelle en
propriété par ailleurs on pourra en
parler éventuellement roulant au pétrole
bon
l'idée de remplacer ce modèle là par un
autre modèle unique qui serait au tout
voiture à pétrole
on va faire le tout voiture électrique
le tout voiture à hydrogène et c'est
sans rien changer de l'organisation des
déplacements par exemple non seulement
dans les centre-villes mais beaucoup
plus largement que ça ça cette idée là
ne fonctionnera d'infos accompagner
cette révolution technologique part
des modifications dans notre
comportement notre rapport à la voiture
ouais serais tenter de vous dire que
deux petites choses d'une part je crois
que dans ce que dit jean syrota ya
quelque chose d'important c'est que le
premier effort qui doit être fait et qui
aura des conséquences bien plus
importantes que l'hypothétique voiture
généralisation de la voiture électrique
c'est d'abord les efforts sur la baisse
des émissions des voitures thermiques et
là on est encore très loin du compte
je le confirme qu'on est en train de
développer de nouveaux moteurs nouvelle
génération chez psa et chez renault des
moteurs qui consommeront deux fois moins
que les plus petits le petit planteur
consommant actuellement franck c'est
vraiment une nouvelle technologie on
arrêtait on a beaucoup avancé sur le
diesel dans technologie on est arrivé à
un pic de technologie sur le
développement de diesel par contre on
avait un peu délaissé les sens et on
réalise qu'on peut aller beaucoup plus
loin maintenant sur les petits moteurs
essence et moteur qui vous consommeront
de l'ide 5,3 litres au cent ce qui est
assez remarquable pour des voitures
d'une taille standard type clio ou de
105 ans qu'on achète d'accord en europe
et de catégorie moyenne un vrai véhicule
où vous transporter votre famille et vos
bagages
les calmars et oui mais maintenant je
crois que ces efforts sont évidemment
affaires qui sont très importants
maintenant la solution si on peut dire
des choses comme ça résident dans le
combiné des efforts tire les efforts des
constructeurs sur le plan technique et
technologique c'est évidemment à
encourager les efforts et là je vais
dire qu'il ya beaucoup encouragé et pas
beaucoup de fait les efforts des
politiques des gouvernements dans les
dents dans l'émission un certain nombre
de normes
on a eu il ya quelques semaines la
négociation de la directive européenne
fin du paquet énergie climat
au plan européen on a été très déçu on
l'a vu au départ des objectifs qui était
sinon relativement ambitieux au moins
raisonnable et sur ses objectifs
raisonnables on a encore baissé
d'ambition je crois que c'est
typiquement ce qu'on ne peut plus se
permettre parce que s'il ya un problème
que pose la voiture thermique pour
compléter ce que disait jean syrota
c'est pas simplement la pollution dans
les centre-villes c'est évidemment
l'enjeu climatique l'hémisphère co2 qui
est un problème j'en tire votre rapport
vous dites que
le passage aux véhicules électriques ne
règlerait pas le problème de la
raréfaction des énergies fossiles
pourtant en france c'est quand même le
nucléaire qui prime oui le véhicule
électrique
il serait alimenté par d'électricité
fabriqués en france par du nucléaire
parce qu elle après coup mais c'est une
situation rare ce prenez l'allemagne se
seraient alimentés avec des centrales à
charbon qui polluent énormément donc le
bilan co2 avec l'électrique en dehors de
la france en dehors de la norvège en
dehors de la suède pour prendre que des
pays européens
il serait très mauvais de ce point de
vue là donc faut faire attention à ce
paramètre là il ya un point que je
voudrais souligner au passage qui permet
de gagner beaucoup de dents la
consommation c'est que les véhicules
électriques qui sont à la mode
aujourd'hui au moins intellectuellement
et leur performance en s'emparant voir
le projet et le point c'est que ces
véhicules ils ont des performances
extrêmement médiocre ans par rapport aux
véhicules à essence d'aujourd'hui la
vitesse de pointe par exemple c'est 110
pour la ville c'est parfait non mais
peut-être qu'à 110 km heure non mais ce
que je voulais souligner aimé qu'à 50
ce que je les soigne et c'est qu'au
contraire c'est peut-être un des
intérêts de ces discussions c'est que si
on faisait des véhicules thermiques dont
la vitesse maximum était de 110 à
l'heure alors là ils consommeraient
seulement à 300 alors monsieur vous
allez avoir le mot de la fin est ce que
c'est un projet sur lequel un schéma sur
lequel vous travaillez
nous avons des constructeurs qu'ils sont
mondiaux
si si renault et psa existe encore c'est
parce qu'ils ne vendent plus que plus
que 30% de leurs modèles en france
donc nous nous vivons dans un monde
global zero globale il faut qu'il
faudrait qu effectivement comme vous le
disiez tout à l'heure que les politiques
applique des règles communes at-il
vraiment à la question là après
effectivement on verra si on peut
toucher des moteurs mais si vous voulez
vendre en allemagne avait respecté le
client allemand nous ont vendu clients
raison tout bien sûr vous attendez qu il
eux-mêmes dans leur rapport à
l'automobile dernière question monsieur
rouzier est ce que vous pensez que cette
mutation se fera forcément par des
restructurations douloureuses dans le
secteur automobile
oui vous aurez de disparition
disparition de certaines activités mais
les créations notre activité donc vous
allez avoir de nouveaux départements qui
fonctionne en garde et des centres de
recherche
il tourne à plein donc les nouvelles
technologies font du travail là dedans
montra bien aller on reste confiant pour
l'avenir grâce aux apports de la
technologie de toujours la volonté la
volonté politique
combien merci messieurs tout de suite
les musées font leur révolution
numérique c'est le sujet parlons blog
ensuite 18h45 face à nous nous
accueillons jean luc mélenchon